Hey everybody. So we have seen so many AI hype cycles around so many different areas, right? We've seen self-driving cars was a big deal in 2009, if people remember that. At the time, Ray Kurzweil has been talking about the singularity forever. Oh, there was even beyond AI, there was Bitcoin and Web3 and all of that. And Patrick and I, we've had folks on, but ourselves, I've kept a little bit of an arm's reach from the latest shiny object syndrome. But I think generative AI is amazing. I'll just put it out there. I don't think it's singularity AGI type stuff, but I do think that there's a tremendous opportunity
大家好。所以我们见过这么多关于不同领域的AI炒作周期，对吧？我们见过2009年的自动驾驶汽车是个大事件，如果大家还记得的话。当时，雷·库兹韦尔一直在谈论奇点。哦，甚至在人工智能之外，还有比特币、Web3以及所有这些。我和帕特里克接待过一些嘉宾，但就我们自己而言，我对最新的“闪亮物体综合症”保持了一定的距离。但我认为生成式AI非常了不起。我就直说了。我不认为这是奇点或通用人工智能（AGI）那类东西，但我确实认为这里面有巨大的机遇
to create value with generative AI. I've been really excited about it. I've been diving deep into the literature and also applications. I know a lot of other folks have too. It's a really exciting area. It's an area that I'm pretty excited about as well. And I'm super excited to have Hagai Levesco on the show. He's the VP of Engineering at Mosaic ML.
用生成式AI创造价值。我一直为此感到非常兴奋。我一直在深入钻研相关文献以及应用。我知道很多其他人也是如此。这是一个非常令人兴奋的领域。这也是一个让我感到相当兴奋的领域。我非常高兴能请到哈盖·莱韦斯科（Hagai Levesco）来到节目中。他是Mosaic ML的工程副总裁。
So thanks for coming on the show, Hagai. Hey, Jason. Hey, Patrick. Thanks for having me. Cool. So we'll definitely dive into generative AI and how folks can use it at home or at their business. But let's start off by talking a little bit about you. What's your background? What was the path that you took that brought you to Mosaic?
谢谢你来到节目，哈盖。嗨，杰森。嗨，帕特里克。谢谢你们邀请我。太好了。我们肯定会深入探讨生成式AI以及人们如何在家里或业务中使用它。但让我们先从简单聊聊你开始。你的背景是什么？你走过怎样的道路才来到Mosaic？
Yeah. So I'm currently the VP of Engineering at Mosaic ML. And I guess we'll probably touch on Mosaic ML a bit later on. But I really started my career a while back now. If there's been video, you could have seen all my gray hair. So I started my career as an engineer, you know, back in Israel where I was born and raised. And really earlier in my career, I did a bunch of things around computer vision, medical imaging, vision for factory automation. I even spent a couple of years living in China, working on a startup there. Wow. So wait, let's dive into that a little bit. So you were in Israel and then the US and then
好的。我目前是Mosaic ML的工程副总裁。我想我们稍后可能会谈到Mosaic ML。但我其实很久以前就开始了我的职业生涯。如果有视频的话，你就能看到我满头白发了。所以我的职业生涯始于一名工程师，你知道的，在我出生和长大的以色列。在职业生涯的早期，我做过很多关于计算机视觉、医学影像、工厂自动化视觉的事情。我甚至在中国的常州（注：原文未具体指出城市，译为中国）生活了几年，在那里的一家初创公司工作。哇。等等，让我们深入探讨一下。所以你在以色列，然后是美国，然后是
China or straight from Israel to China? No, yeah. So straight from Israel to China. And so what was that like? That was, it must be a huge culture shock. It was definitely initially a shock and then really a fantastic experience because, you know, as we all know, China is even today, actually, you know, kind of growing rapidly.
中国，还是直接从以色列去中国？不，是的。直接从以色列去中国。那感觉是怎样的？那绝对一开始是个冲击，然后是一次真正美妙的经历，因为，如我们所知，中国甚至在今天，实际上也在，你知道的，快速增长。
Back then it was really superb, you know, moving super, super quickly. So just the story is, you know, I was a young engineer back then, had some experience, expertise in computer vision. And, you know, this was actually, so just to put things on kind of on the timeline, this was pre the deep learning revolution. So I'm talking about 2007 80s you know neural networks were not working well so computer vision actually was completely different like the way you apply
那时候真的很棒，你知道的，发展得超级、超级快。所以故事是这样的，我当时是个年轻的工程师，有一些计算机视觉的经验和专业知识。你知道，这其实——为了把事情放在时间线上——这是在深度学习革命之前。所以我是指2007、2008年左右，你知道，神经网络当时运行得并不好，所以计算机视觉实际上完全不同，比如你应用
computer vision to a to a problem yeah just just to put put context i think you know there's a bunch of hand-coded things right like there was these i remember patrick probably knows this way better than i do but there was um a whole bunch of filters, right? Like Sobel filter and these like directional filters. And you would basically try to build your own deep learning system by just stacking all of these filters as an expert. And then at the end, you would have some shallow model that, you know, is stacked on top of all these other things. Exactly. That was exactly the way you'd apply, you know, define different filters, you would hand tune them. I mean, today from, you know, computer vision neural networks, the
计算机视觉解决问题的方式。是的，为了提供背景，我认为有很多手工编写的东西，比如我记得——帕特里克可能比我更清楚这一点——但有……一大堆滤波器，对吧？比如索贝尔滤波器（Sobel filter）和这些方向性滤波器。你基本上是想通过作为一名专家将所有这些滤波器堆叠在一起来构建你自己的深度学习系统。然后在最后，你会得到一些浅层模型，你知道，它堆叠在所有这些其他东西之上。没错。这完全就是你应用的方式，你知道的，定义不同的滤波器，你手动调整它们。我的意思是，从今天的计算机视觉神经网络来看，
convolution kernels are kind of, you know, figured out during the training process. Back then, we would use convolution quite a bit bit and you would hand tune the convolution to work for your problem. That was actually a lot of fun. It was really interesting process. Of course, it made kind of the solutions not super scalable where for different customers, different problems,
卷积核在训练过程中会被摸索出来，可以说是这样的。而在当时，我们要大量使用卷积，你会手动调整卷积使其适应你的问题。那其实非常有趣。这是一个非常有趣的过程。当然，这使得解决方案的可扩展性不是很高，因为对于不同的客户、不同的问题，
you'd have to sit down and tweak things. You know, field engineers, that's a lot of what they would do. They would sit down with these systems and tweak the the parameters including the convolution kernels by hand oh wow that's that's wild yeah because you know when you're when the convolution kernel is not doesn't know anything about your objective like it's trying to like find edges but that's not your objective your objective is to say like is there a face in this picture
你必须坐下来调整各种参数。你知道，现场工程师很大一部分工作就是这样。他们会坐在这些系统前，手动调整包括卷积核在内的参数。哦，哇，太疯狂了。是的，因为你知道，当卷积核对你的目标一无所知时——它试图寻找边缘，但这不是你的目标，你的目标是说：这张照片里有人脸吗？
and edges just happen to be kind of like tangentially and you know interesting to that that objective and so then it's like can you come up with a filter it's even more interesting and then yeah to your point deep learning now just does everything for us which is pretty wild yeah and it's even more than that like Like you had to, usually typically in a typical computer vision pipeline, you know, you'd start by taking the input image and then preparing it to be kind of ready for the convolution operator. So you'd have to do different tricks. It was like a whole toolbox of tricks you do to like clean up the image, you know, normalize it manually, and then start scrubbing the image with different
而边缘恰好在某种程度上与该目标切线相关且有趣，然后就会变成：你能设计出一个更有趣的滤波器吗？然后，是的，正如你所说，深度学习现在为我们做了一切，这真是太疯狂了。是的，不仅如此。就像你必须——通常在典型的计算机视觉流水线中，你知道，你会从输入图像开始，然后准备好让它适应卷积算子。所以你必须使用不同的技巧。这就像一整套用于清理图像的技巧工具箱，你知道，手动将其归一化，然后开始用不同的
morphological operators. Yeah, so it was quite a ride. But going back to kind of the experience in China, so, you know, I was just married back then. I asked my wife, hey, do you want to go to an adventure in China? And she initially said no. And then I was able to convince her that it's going to be kind of an experience of a lifetime. And we just hopped on the plane.
形态学算子去擦洗图像。是的，所以那是一段相当奇妙的旅程。但回到在中国的经历，你知道，我当时刚结婚，我问我妻子：“嘿，你想去中国冒险吗？”她最初说不。然后我成功说服她，这将是一次一生难忘的经历，我们就跳上了飞机。
It was a small company, startup, like maybe five people. They brought me in as sort of the computer vision expert, although definitely there was tons of, you know, I wasn't that of an expert, but, you know, I said, what the heck? And we built a whole system, including hardware. Of course, the differentiator of the system was the software, but it was hardware with,
那是一家小公司，一家初创公司，可能只有五个人左右。他们把我招进去担任某种计算机视觉专家，尽管绝对有大量……其实我并不是那么专家，但你知道，我想管他呢，我们就构建了整个系统，包括硬件。当然，该系统的差异化在于软件，但它包含了硬件，
you know, robotics to, you know, from conveyor belts controlled by, you know by by different actuators through imaging system lighting cameras through integration with the automation in a typical factory and that product was for the pcb industry the printed circuit board industry oh cool yeah yeah, you know, we built a product from scratch. We're able to, you know, sell it to a few companies. I spent a lot of time on factory floors in China, which is by itself is an experience. Oh, I bet. I heard they're massive. They're massive.
带有机器人技术，你知道的，从由不同执行器控制的传送带，到成像系统、照明相机，再到与典型工厂中自动化的集成，该产品是针对PCB行业，也就是印刷电路板行业的。哦，酷。是的，我们从头开始构建了一个产品。我们能够将其出售给几家公司。我在中国的工厂车间里度过了很多时间，这本身就是一种经历。哦，我敢打赌。我听说它们规模宏大。它们太宏大了。
It's like a city. Now, you know what's funny? I mean, I'm from Israel. So when I was growing up as a kid, Israel was about like 6 million people. And by the way, just for context, I think Israel is often in the news, but many people don't realize that it's tiny, both in terms of population and geographical size. It's actually smaller than the state of New Jersey in terms of the size. Oh, I never knew that. Yeah. So, I mean, you know, here I am coming from Israel, you know, six million people country, moving to China, going to a suburb of Shanghai.
就像一座城市。现在，你知道有趣的是什么吗？我是以色列人。所以当我小时候长大的时候，以色列大约只有600万人口。顺便说一下，作为背景，我认为以色列经常出现在新闻中，但许多人没有意识到它非常小，无论是在人口还是地理面积方面。就面积而言，它实际上比新泽西州还要小。哦，我从来不知道这一点。是的。所以，你看，我从以色列来到这里，一个600万人口的国家，搬到中国，去到上海的一个卫星城。
And that suburb was, you know, a small suburb, six million people. So, yeah, just the size of China is massive. And yeah, so, you know, it was fun. Are there tours? Like, let's say, I've never been to China, I'll be honest. I would love to go. I just never had the opportunity. But if I went, could I tour a factory?
而那个卫星城是一个小卫星城，有600万人口。所以，是的，中国就是如此巨大。是的，所以这很有趣。有没有这种旅行？比如说，我从来没去过中国，老实说。我很想去。我只是从来没有机会。但如果我去了，我能参观工厂吗？
Like, is that a thing that tourists do or not really? I think it's a great idea for a startup, Jason. But no, I don't think it's an option. But these factories are really interesting because they're like little cities, literally little cities. One of our first customers was actually a factory owned by a Taiwanese company and wasn't considered a very big factory, but it had 50,000 workers. Wow. Oh,000 workers. Wow. Oh, my goodness. So, you know, five times 10 to the power of four.
像这种事是游客会做的，还是其实不会？我认为这对创业公司来说是个好主意，杰森。但不会，我不认为这是一个选项。但这些工厂真的很有趣，因为它们就像小城市，字面意义上的小城市。我们的第一批客户之一其实是一家台湾公司拥有的工厂，它不被认为是一个非常大的工厂，但它有5万名工人。哇。哦，5万名工人。哇。我的天哪。所以，你知道，5乘以10的4次方。
And what you realize after you go there is, first of all, most of the workers are fairly young, meaning, you know, 18-ish. And they actually live in the factory. Oh. 18-ish and they actually live in the factory and they have dorms there they have everything they need like you know food social activities you know places to work out it's it's literally almost like a student dorm only you work you don't study so I found that really interesting yeah one of the things that that blew my mind was this is a long time ago um but they interviewed Tim Cook and they were talking about manufacturing like what it's like because I think this is the time where they're making the Mac Pro in America and they were talking about the difference there and what he he said was, in China, if you need a million people,
你去过之后就会意识到，首先，大多数工人相当年轻，也就是18岁左右。他们实际上住在工厂里。哦。18岁左右，他们实际上住在工厂里，那里有他们的宿舍，有他们需要的一切，比如食物、社交活动、锻炼的地方，它字面意义上几乎就像学生宿舍，只是你工作而不是学习，所以我发现这真的很有趣。是的，让我感到震撼的一件事是——这是很久以前的事了——他们采访了蒂姆·库克（Tim Cook），他们在谈论制造业，谈论它是什么样子的，因为我认为这是他们在美国制造Mac Pro的时候，他们在讨论那里的差异，而他说的是：在中国，如果你需要100万人，
literally, like you need 1 million people to show up to like, you know, boost the iPhone, you know, production, you can get a million people. And when he said that, and he wasn't, wasn't hyperbolic. I mean, he literally meant it that it really that hit home on this kind of scale we're talking about. Yeah. And China, by the way, is not done with that process. There are still, the majority of the Chinese population is still in villages and looking to go to the city where they can find, you know, have work, get proper, you know, wages, you know, and start their lives. And this is part of what I think many people don't understand about the Chinese, you know, China and the Chinese government is that they are under immense pressure to sustain growth so that their masses actually kind of have a path to a better life. And that's part of why they're so aggressive on growth.
字面意义上，比如你需要100万人来支援，你知道的，提升iPhone的生产，你能找到100万人。当他说这话时，他并不是在夸张。我是说，他是字面意思，这真正让人深刻体会到我们所谈论的这种规模。是的。顺便说一下，中国还没有完成这个过程。中国的大多数人口仍然在村庄里，希望前往能够找到工作、获得得体工资并开始生活的城市。这就是为什么我认为许多人不理解中国和中国政府的原因之一，他们承受着巨大的增长压力，以便让大众真正有一条通往更好生活的道路。这也是他们对增长如此激进的部分原因。
They just have to grow very quickly to kind of, you know, serve that need of their population. That makes sense. So what happened to the startup? Did the startup grow very quickly or no? you know, serve that need of their population. That makes sense. So what happened to the startup? Did the startup grow very quickly or no? So it started well. And then, you know, I don't know how much, how many of the listeners know,
他们只是必须非常快速地增长，以满足其人口的这种需求。这说得通。那么那家初创公司怎么样了？这家初创公司发展得非常快吗？还是没有？满足其人口的这种需求。这说得通。那么那家初创公司怎么样了？这家初创公司发展得非常快吗？还是没有？所以它开局不错。然后，你知道，我不知道有多少听众知道，
but 2008 slash nine, there was a pretty massive financial crisis. And we were hit, the startup was hit very significantly by that crisis. It started as the mortgage crisis in the US and then very quickly kind of expanded globally. As often is the case, right, when there is a crisis, people start cutting back on their purchases and then the PCB industry was hit significantly.
但在2008到2009年，发生了一场相当大规模的金融危机。我们受到了冲击，那家初创公司受到了这场危机的严重冲击。它始于美国的抵押贷款危机，然后非常迅速地在全球范围内蔓延。通常情况都是这样，对吧？当危机发生时，人们开始削减购买开支，然后PCB行业受到了严重冲击。
So did the chip industry, just because the demand for devices went significantly down. So the startup didn't shut down, but it definitely kind of were on a good trajectory. And then it just kind of, you know, most of the orders were cut back, budgets were cut back. Yeah, so, but we were able to still work through things. However, at some point I had some family issues.
芯片行业也是如此，因为对设备的需求显著下降。所以这家初创公司并没有倒闭，但它的发展势头本来很好。然后它就变成这样了，你知道，大部分订单被削减，预算被削减。是的，所以，我们仍然能够度过难关。然而，在某个时候我有一些家庭问题。
I had to go back to Israel. That was about, you know, two years later. So I went back to Israel and, you know, for a while I was flying to China every month, but it's really unsustainable, especially when you have a young family that needs, you know, needs you to be there for them. And I had my first son who was born. So at some point I just parted ways with the startup. Yep that makes sense and so then after that you were oh so at that point you were back in Israel at some point you were at the US what happened there? Yeah so went back to Israel and then kind of I went back to working in an area that I had some experience on before, medical imaging. So, yeah, I actually went to work for GE Healthcare in Israel
我不得不回以色列。那大约是两年后。所以我回到了以色列，你知道，有一段时间我每个月都飞往中国，但这真的不可持续，特别是当你有一个年轻的家庭，需要你在那里陪伴他们的时候。我的第一个儿子出生了。所以在某个时候我只是和那家初创公司分道扬镳了。是的，这说得通。所以在那之后你——哦，所以当时你回到了以色列，在某个时候你去了美国，那里发生了什么？是的，所以回到以色列，然后我回去从事我以前有一些经验的领域，医学影像。所以，是的，我其实去以色列的GE医疗（GE Healthcare）工作了，
and we built a cardiovascular imaging system, which was, you know, really a lot of fun. And I think for those that have worked in healthcare, you know, there are definitely some downsides. Like it's a very slow moving field because of a lot of regulation. And in general, the audience is very, customer base is very conservative. But then you really feel, on the plus side, you really feel that you're changing the world for the better. Because if you can develop systems that give better care, help detect diseases earlier, help treat diseases. It's really something that, you know,
我们构建了一个心血管成像系统，这真的非常有趣。我想对于那些在医疗保健领域工作过的人来说，你肯定知道有一些缺点。由于大量的监管，这是一个发展非常缓慢的领域。而且总的来说，受众非常保守，客户群非常保守。但从积极的一面来看，你真的会觉得你在为了更好的世界而改变。因为如果你能开发出提供更好护理、帮助更早检测疾病、帮助治疗疾病的系统。这真的是一件，你知道的，
you feel really good about, right, doing. So I did that for a while. And then, you know, Amazon reached out and they didn't have an R&D office in Israel back then. I mean, now they have tons of R&D offices in Israel, but back then they did not. And they interviewed me and then asked to relocate me to the US.
你做起来会觉得非常有成就感的事，对吧？我做了一段时间。然后，亚马逊联系了我，他们当时在以色列没有研发办公室。我的意思是，现在他们在以色列有大量的研发办公室，但当时没有。他们面试了我，然后要求把我调到美国。
Ah, so you went to Seattle. No, so they wanted to relocate me to Seattle. But again, I mentioned my wife earlier and how she had to approve moving to China. So again, my wife is the decision maker on these things. And after thinking about that together, Seattle was not the right place for us in terms of just the weather, family.
啊，所以你去了西雅图。不，所以他们想把我调到西雅图。但再次说明，我刚才提到了我妻子以及她如何必须批准去中国。所以再次说明，我妻子是这些事情的决策者。我们一起考虑之后，就天气和家庭而言，西雅图对我们来说并不是一个合适的地方。
So we moved to the Bay Area. Ah, okay, got it. So I know Amazon has this like Lab 126 or that that's where the kindle came out of and some of these things is that where you went or was there a separate office um no so the opportunity at least you know amazon kind of offered me back then was actually to join amazon music in sf amazon music back then was a relatively small team. It was a very basic product back then. They were kind of following the iTunes model. And again, for folks that are a bit older like me,
所以我们搬到了湾区。啊，好的，明白了。我知道亚马逊有这个Lab 126，Kindle就是从那里出来的，还有一些其他东西，你是去了那里，还是有一个单独的办公室？不，亚马逊当时提供给我的机会实际上是加入旧金山的亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）。当时的亚马逊音乐是一个相对较小的团队。当时它是一个非常基础的产品。他们有点在效仿iTunes模式。同样，对于像我这样年龄稍大一点的人来说，
you'd know that digital music actually started by selling songs. So you would buy a song, you would buy an album, you would pay for it, you would have the rights to a digital copy and you know you can deploy it on your uh you know whatever players you had audio streaming was not hardly a thing back then i mean now it's how all of us consume you know music and more than music but back then the technology was not there the business terms were not there so it was a very different world but i joined amazon music at a really amazing time where streaming just started picking up so i actually helped ship amazon music starting in the us and then we expanded globally and that was really super
你会知道数字音乐其实是从销售歌曲开始的。所以你会买一首歌，买一张专辑，你为此付费，你拥有数字副本的权利，你知道你可以把它部署到你的，你知道的，你拥有的任何播放器上。音频流媒体在当时几乎不存在——我的意思是，现在这是我们所有人消费音乐以及音乐之外内容的方式，但在当时技术还没到位，商业条款也没到位，所以这是一个非常不同的世界。但我加入亚马逊音乐是在一个真正美妙的时刻，当时流媒体刚刚开始起步。所以我实际上参与了从美国开始的亚马逊音乐的发布，然后我们扩展到了全球，这真的是一个超级酷的经历，因为它是……的一部分，我们正在参与那场将音乐从下载的数字内容转变为流媒体数字内容的革命，这对整个行业来说是一场巨大的革命。
cool experience because it was part of you know we're participating in that revolution of kind of taking music from being you know download digital content to streaming digital content and that was that was you know a huge revolution for the the entire industry yeah i feel like uh this is you know obviously out of out of my depth but i do feel like just thinking about it economically, it better aligns the incentives, right? Because I remember, I definitely remember, you know, I was huge into, you know, bands and going to concerts, you know, in high school and even in middle school. I think there was one year in high school where I went to something like a hundred shows in one year, and I still had all the tickets and everything. I mean, not big bands, because that would, you know,
是的，我觉得——这显然超出了我的理解范围，但我确实觉得，仅仅从经济角度去思考，它更好地调整了激励机制，对吧？因为我记得，我绝对记得，我在高中甚至初中时非常迷恋乐队和去听音乐会。我想我在高中有那么一年，在一年内去了大约一百场演出，我仍然保留着所有的票根和一切。我的意思是，不是大乐队，因为那会，你知道的，
that would be, that would break the bank, but, you know, a bunch of the tickets and everything. I mean, not big bands, because that would break the bank, but a bunch of local shows and everything. And there were times where I saw an album and the cover. This is back when we were buying CDs. The cover looked awesome. And I'd never heard the band before, but the artwork looked really great. So I bought it and then the songs were terrible.
那会让人倾家荡产，但你知道，有很多票根之类的。我的意思是，不是大乐队，那会让人倾家荡产，而是一堆当地的演出。有时我看到一张专辑和它的封面——那是我们买CD的年代。封面看起来棒极了。我以前从未听说过这个乐队，但艺术设计看起来真的很棒。所以我买了下来，结果歌曲太糟糕了。
And so it's like, okay, well, I lost 10 bucks and so now you know because it's streaming you know the songs that you enjoy that you listen to again and again if that that time is logged and then that credit is assigned you know to the appropriate musician and so and so now i mean the sad part of it is no one cares about album art anymore but the good part of it is that people are just laser focused on the music and the message. Yeah, yeah. I think it definitely really revolutionized the entire music industry. It also increased the pie. And that's, I think, it's a good lesson, by the way, because I think whenever there's
所以这就好像，好吧，我损失了10美元，所以现在你知道，因为有了流媒体，你知道你喜欢并一遍又一遍聆听的歌曲，如果这段时间被记录下来，然后相应的版权收入就会分配给适当的音乐家，所以现在——悲伤的部分是，没有人再关心专辑封面了，但积极的部分是，人们只是专注于音乐和信息本身。是的，是的。我认为它绝对彻底革新了整个音乐产业。它还把蛋糕做大了。我认为，这是一个很好的教训，顺便说一下，因为我认为每当
a new technology that comes by, there's always the kind of the pushback, right? Especially when it's a fundamental technology that changes how people, you know, interact with content, for example, or interact with technology. There's always a pushback because, you know, very naturally people are concerned. And we'll get to AI, I guess, later. But I think we all can see similar patterns. But in reality, first of all, these technology changes are something, you know, usually you cannot block.
有新技术出现时，总是会有阻力，对吧？特别是当这是一项改变人们与内容互动方式（例如）或与技术互动方式的基础技术时。总是会有阻力，因为很自然地，人们会感到担忧。我想我们稍后会谈到人工智能。但我想我们都能看到类似模式。但实际上，首先，这些技术变革通常是你无法阻挡的。
You can, you know, slow them down a little bit if you really try hard, but you can't block. But second of all, they're usually opening up really new opportunities, business opportunities, consumption opportunities, education opportunities, and whatnot. They typically tend to be for the best or at least have a path that is for the best. And in the music industry, yeah, there was a lot of pushback from the big labels, the companies that control the rights to most of the content, at least on the Western world. But eventually they kind of, you know, went along with it.
如果你真的很努力，你可以把它们放慢一点，但你无法阻挡。但其次，它们通常会打开全新的机遇、商业机遇、消费机遇、教育机遇等等。它们往往倾向于朝着最好的方向发展，或者至少有一条通往最好的道路。在音乐产业中，是的，来自大型唱片公司的阻力很大，这些公司控制着至少在西方世界的大部分内容的版权。但最终他们还是顺应了潮流。
And now if you look at the revenue of the music industry from streaming, obviously it's much bigger than, you know, CD sales. But it's also in just if you look at the entire streaming revenue versus what cd sales were its peak uh streaming is now a bigger business so uh and it's not surprising right we all have now phones in our pockets which is also audio streaming devices and just the reach of content is much more much more broad today yeah that's right. And actually, kind of a little foreshadowing here, but one of the most popular trending folks on Spotify was AI Drake, which is an AI version of Drake.
现在，如果你看看音乐产业来自流媒体的收入，显然它比CD销量要大得多。但如果你看看整个流媒体收入与CD销量巅峰时期的对比，流媒体现在已经是一个更大的业务了——所以，这并不令人意外，对吧？我们现在所有人兜里都有手机，这也是音频流媒体设备，今天内容的覆盖面要广泛得多。是的，没错。实际上，这里有点像做铺垫，Spotify上最受欢迎的流行人物之一是AI德雷克（AI Drake），这是德雷克的人工智能版本。
And I was, I listened to some of the tracks and I was blown away. I think they eventually got banned from Spotify because they were using drake's face as their face and so that you can't do that um but they were i want to say in the top 10 of trending for spotify which got my attention it and i listened to it it sounded amazing um i actually was really shocked even with everything we've seen so far with gender i was really shocked at the quality of it come to find out that actually a person wrote the lyrics so i i kind of you know i thought that it was all the way ai where someone just pressed a button but uh but no a person did write
我听了一些曲目，感到大开眼界。我想他们最终被Spotify封禁了，因为他们用了德雷克的脸作为他们的脸，这是不被允许的，但他们在Spotify的热门趋势中排在前10名之内，这引起了我的注意，我听了，听起来棒极了。实际上我真的很震惊，尽管我们之前看到了生成式AI的各种成果，但我对它的质量感到非常震惊。后来发现，其实歌词是一个人写的。所以我当时想——我以为完全是AI，有人按了一个按钮，但并不是，歌词确实由一个人写的。
the lyrics but the the text is speech you know and getting the music and getting it all to match the rhythm and everything it was just flawless i mean it, if you haven't yet, I don't think it's on Spotify anymore. I'm not sure what happened there. But you can definitely go on YouTube and look up AI Drake and listen to these songs. It's pretty wild. Amazing. Yeah. Anyway, so going back to kind of my story.
但语音转文本，以及获取音乐并使所有这一切与节奏和其他一切相匹配，简直是完美无瑕。我是说，如果你还没听过的话——我不认为它还在Spotify上。我不确定那里发生了什么。但你绝对可以在YouTube上搜索“AI Drake”并听听这些歌。这真是太疯狂了。太棒了。是的。无论如何，回到我自己的故事。
So I spent some time in Amazon Music. It was a lot of fun, but it also very new to me. I mean, it wasn't about computer vision, obviously. It was also about machine learning, which I was anyway, you know, didn't do a lot of things on, you know, outside of my graduate studies and, you know, what applies to computer vision. I was focusing over there more on algorithms for audio streaming, web applications, you know, scaling this from, you know, millions of customers in the US to tens of millions and later even more globally. And also, I think for me, I would just, you know,
所以我花了一些时间在亚马逊音乐。这很有趣，但对我也非常新鲜。我的意思是，这显然与计算机视觉无关。这也与机器学习有关，无论如何，除了我的研究生研究以及适用于计算机视觉的内容之外，我并没有做太多这方面的事情。我在那里更多地专注于音频流媒体的算法、Web应用程序，将这些从美国的数千万客户扩展到全球的数千万甚至更多。而且，我也觉得，我刚刚从以色列搬到湾区。这里的文化非常不同。开发技术的方式，比如公司内部的文化是不同的。开发技术的方式，比如公司内部的文化是不同的。我在很大程度上确实在适应这一切。你为什么不深入探讨一下呢？就像——因为我和帕特里克几乎一辈子都在美国生活。我在意大利住了两个月，除此之外我一辈子都住在美国或加拿大。那么，关于这里的
relocated from Israel to the Bay Area. The culture was very different. The way technology is developed, like the culture within the companies were different. The way technology is developed, like the culture within the companies were different. And I was, you know, to a large degree, really adapting to that. Why don't you double click on that? Like what is, you know, because Patrick and I have basically been in the US our whole lives. I lived in Italy for two months, other than that I've lived in the US or Canada my whole life. And so what really struck you about like,
文化以及公司文化，有什么真正震撼你的地方吗？是的，哇，我甚至不知道从哪里开始，因为这些变化——这些差异相当显著。所以，我先从——在以色列，以色列的文化非常随性，也非常直接。不管好坏，你知道的，人们在有话要说时往往不会拐弯抹角。
maybe, you know, culture and then corporate culture over here? Yeah, so, wow, I don't even know where to start, because the changes are, you know, the differences are pretty significant. So, you know, I started by, you know, in Israel, Israel's culture is, you know, very casual and also very direct. For better or worse, you know, people, you know, would often, you know, not beat around the bushes when they have something to say. You know, they'll tell it to you in your face, even if it may be a bit offending. And in Israel, it's not considered offending. It's just, you know, people tell it for what it is.
他们会当面告诉你，即使这可能会有点冒犯。在以色列，这不被认为是被冒犯。这只是，你知道的，人们有什么说什么。我认为在美国，人们往往会，我不必用“尊重”这个词。只是在表达事情时更有策略。所以当他们有困难的话要说，或者有一些重要的反馈时，他们会以一种非常温和的方式分享。所以对我来说，最初我必须真正调整我的降噪功能，以便真正了解，如果人们说了什么，即使他们以一种非常
I think in the US, you know, people tend to be, I don't have to use the word respectful. It just kind of be more, you know, have more tact around saying things. So when they have something, you know, difficult to say or have some significant feedback, you know, they would share it in a way that is very processed. So for me initially, I had to, you know, really adjust, right, my noise cancellation. So, you know, to really learn that, you know, if people say something, even if they say it in a really,
友好的方式说出来，我也必须更深入地解读它，因为我习惯了：嘿，如果有人有重要的事情要说，如果它对正在发生的事情或我做过的事情有所批评，根据我在以色列的经历和我长大的方式，它会非常直接地表达出来。在美国，我不得不学会更好地理解这些细微差别。这绝对能引起我的共鸣。你知道的，就像我和帕特里克在东海岸长大，或者我想你可能会叫它南方，东南方。但是，你知道的，在搬到加利福尼亚之后，我想我表达它的方式——我并没有真正告诉别人这一点，因为它也
you know, nice way, I have to read a little bit more into it just because I'm used to, hey, if someone has something important to say and if it's critical of something that is going on or something that I have done, it would come from my experience in Israel and the way I grew up, it would come very directly. In the US, I had to learn to understand the nuances a little bit better. That definitely resonates with me. You know, like Patrick and I grew up on the East Coast, or I guess maybe you'd call it the South, I mean, Southeast. But, you know, in moving to California, you know, I think the way I kind of expressed it, I didn't really tell people this because it also
缺乏策略。但为了解释一下，我当时觉得我周围的人被动攻击，而我是主动攻击。但是的，我觉得类似于你所说的那样。我只是把话说出来，而其他遇到的人，尤其是在企业界，我会意识到，你过了一天才说，“哦，这个人实际上，他们实际上对这个真的很开心，或者对那个真的很沮丧。”这就好像信号中故意加入了一些噪音，去尝试着，我不知道这是什么。也许这就像是对任何事情都有合理的否认。
lacks tact. But just to like explain it, I kind of felt like the people around me were passive aggressive and I was actively aggressive. But yeah, I felt like similar to what you were saying. I would just say stuff and then other people that would meet, especially in the corporate world, I would realize, you're saying a day later, oh, this person actually, they were actually, you know, really happy with this or really upset with that. It's like there's intentionally, you know, a bit of noise in the signal to try to, yeah, I don't know what it is. Maybe it's like there's always plausible deniability of everything.
你知道，这只是一种礼貌的事情。但是，是的，尽管我一直在这里长大，但我不得不经历同样的经历。任何事，你知道，这只是一件礼貌的事；但是，是的，即使我一生都在这里长大，我也必须经历同样的经历。是的，我认为正如你所说，美国是一个很大的地方，所以我想我的经历主要基于加利福尼亚的文化，而美国其他地区的文化，就像你说的，可能多少有些不同。但，是的，你知道，这是差异之一。我认为另一件我认为实际上很一致的事情，只是做法略有不同，以色列与加利福尼亚相比，是主动采取行动和跳出框框思考。
You know, it's just, it's like a politeness thing. But yeah, even though I've grown up here the whole time, I had to go through the same experience. everything you know it's just it's like a politeness thing but uh but yeah i i even though i've grown up here the whole time i i had to go through the same experiences yeah and i think to your point it's you know the u.s is a very big place so i guess my experience has been based mostly on the you know the culture in california and other areas in the u.s right like you said are probably you, you know, somewhat different. But, yeah, you know, this is one of the differences. I think the other thing, which I actually think that is kind of aligned, actually,
你知道，以色列是一个小国，在一个有很多安全问题的地区长大，所以以色列人往往是非常有创造力的跳出框框思考者，而且对现状也没有太多的尊重，对吧？你总是会想出能把事情做得更好的方法。毫无疑问，人均来看，以色列在初创公司数量上排名第一，对吧？创立初创公司。这很大程度上源于这种以色列的心态和文化。
just done a bit differently, you know, Israel versus California is, you know, taking initiative and thinking out of the box you know israel is a you know small country grew up you know israel kind of was developed in an area with a lot of security you know problems so israelis tend to be very you know creative out of the box thinkers and also you know don't have too many too much respect for the way things are done, right? It's like you always think about ways you can do something better. And, you know, not surprisingly, per capita, Israel is the number one country in terms of startup, right? Founding startups. A lot of it comes from that Israeli mindset and culture.
我认为这其实是——加利福尼亚实际上非常相似，也许原因不同。但在加利福尼亚，独立思考、跳出框框思考、主动采取行动、不顺从现状也被鼓励，甚至可能是被强调的东西。被强调，是的，这说得通。是的，这很有趣，我觉得确实有一种真正的独立精神，你知道，如果你去像——我没去过以色列，但如果你去印度，例如，它感觉就像是一个自由主义者的天堂，因为有这么多小公司。如果警察逮捕你，你只要直接给他钱就行了。你知道的，你不需要上庭。
I do think this is, you know, California is actually kind of very similar, maybe for different reasons. But in California, also kind of independent thinking, thinking out of the box, taking initiative, not conforming with status quo is, I feel is kind of encouraged and even maybe, you know, something that is highlighted's highlighted yeah that makes sense yeah it's interesting i think i do feel like there's there's like a real independent spirit you know if you visit places like i've never been to israel but if you visit india for example it felt like like a libertarian paradise because there's so many small companies. If a policeman arrests you, you just give him money one-to-one. You know, you don't have to go to court.
所以它给人的感觉就是，是的，如果自由主义者把事情推向极限，你就会得到那种结果。我确实觉得在美国，有太多的结构，尤其是在医疗保健领域。这有利有弊，但它确实是不同的。
And so it just kind of felt like, yeah, like if the libertarian folks, if you kind of like take it to the limit, that's what you would get. I do feel like in the US, there is just, and healthcare particularly, there's just so much structure. And there's pros and cons to that, but it is different for sure.
你曾在亚马逊工作，然后不知怎么地进入了……所以这有点像是进入AI的引子，你对推荐系统以及这些大规模AI的一些介绍，以及用计算机视觉做的事情的延伸。然后从那到全身心投入AI的道路是怎样的？接下来发生了什么？是的，我在亚马逊音乐工作了几年，然后觉得，嘿，我需要改变一下。然后我在亚马逊内部调到了AWS，亚马逊云科技。当时，AWS已经是一个快速增长且规模相当大的业务了。所以今天，AWS是亚马逊内部每年产生约850亿美元收入的业务，这太庞大了，对吧？
You were at Amazon and then at some point you got into... So that kind of was sort of like an intro to AI, your sort of introduction to recommender systems and some of these kind of large-scale AI and kind of augmenting what you did with computer vision. And then what's the path from that to being kind of like all in on AI? What happened next? Yeah, so I spent a few years working in Amazon Music and then kind of decided, hey, I need a change. And then I moved within Amazon to AWS, Amazon Web Services. And back then, AWS was already kind of a rapidly growing business that was already fairly large. So today, AWS is a business in Amazon that generates about $85 billion in revenue every year, which is just massive, right?
如果它是一家独立的公司，它将成为软件收入方面最大的五家软件公司之一。但当时，它没那么大，但也相当大了。但他们当时的机器学习产品非常有限。然后他们加倍投入。我认为这是一个非常有趣的领域，我想成为其中的一部分。而且，我很幸运，他们接受了我。在特拉维夫大学读硕士期间，我在其他科目之外还学习了一点机器学习。就像许多其他人一样，你们这些当年学计算机科学的人，机器学习在当时并不像今天这样占据统治地位。当时我们正在构建AWS SageMaker。那今天是AWS提供的一个非常成功的机器学习平台。这是一项大业务。据我所知，它是AWS历史上增长最快的服务。所以我加入了那个团队，为SageMaker做出了贡献，并致力于深度学习框架。
Like if it would be its own company, it would have been one of the five biggest software companies out there in terms of software revenue. But back then, it was not that big, but still fairly big. But their machine learning offering was very limited back then. And then they doubled down on it. And I thought that was a really interesting area to be part of. And, you know, I was fortunate enough that they accepted to take me in. In my master's degree in Tel Aviv University, I studied a little bit about, you know, machine learning, among other things. Just like many other folks, you folks who did the CS back then, machine learning was not what it is
当时，AWS试图加倍押注一个名为MXNet的框架，它有点类似于TensorFlow或PyTorch，只是它没有这两个框架那么成功。这很难。我的意思是，我惊叹于PyTorch能够占据领先地位。是的，我有——是的，我认为这真的很有趣。我肯定从中学到了很多教训，因为我当时在那个失败的团队里。
today in terms of the dominance. Back then, we were building AWS SageMaker. That's today a very successful machine learning platform offered by AWS. It's a big business. From what I hear, it's the fastest service in AWS's history in terms of growth. So I joined that team and then contributed to SageMaker, worked on deep learning frameworks.
我在MXNet团队。我认为，你从那些没有按计划进行的事情中学到了很多。通常情况下，你从没有按计划进行的事情或失败中学到的东西，实际上比从成功中学到的要多。因为成功，你倾向于把它归功于你自己，你自己和你的团队，仅此而已。但面对失败，你会被迫更深入地思考为什么事情没有成功。
Back then, AWS tries to double down on a framework called MXNet, which is kind of similar to TensorFlow or PyTorch, only it wasn't successful as both of these frameworks. It's tough. I mean, I'm amazed PyTorch was able to take the lead. Yeah. And I had, yeah, I think that was really interesting. I definitely took a lot of lessons from that because, you know, I was on the team that
是的，我很想听听你的看法，因为我不知道这一切是如何发展的。这有点——我绝对是TensorFlow和PyTorch的用户。但PyTorch是如何取得领先并超越所有人的呢？你知道，我想，MXNet犯了哪些错误，或者PyTorch填补了哪些空白，才让他们能够做到这一点？是的，我认为我观察到的一些事情——当然我认为还有很多其他的角度——但首要的一点是，易用性是最重要的，对吧？而且我认为，特别是作为工程师的我们，有时会低估易用性，认为：
lost. I was on the MXNet team. And I think, you know, you learn a lot from things that don't work according to plan. Typically, you actually learn more from the things that don't work according to plan or fail than from your success. Because success, you tend to attribute it to yourself and, you know, yourself and your team and that's it. But failure is you're kind of forced to think harder, right, about why things didn't work out.
“不，易用性，这很相似，对吧？人们可以通过不同的方式达到相同的目标。一种方式可能比另一种更复杂，但没关系。性能更重要。”这是一个非常常见的陷阱。我绝对认为在MXNet方面，我们肯定陷入了那个陷阱，我们为性能进行了优化，而不是为易用性优化。所以我认为这是一个关键的教训。而且我认为，每一个工具开发者、平台开发者、框架开发者，我都建议永远把易用性放在最重要的位置。性能，你以后可以迎头赶上。事实上，对于人们来说，当他们开始使用时，他们通常不会过多地看性能。他们会更多地关注易用性，看它有多容易上手，有多容易学习，有多容易扩展？将它应用到核心问题上有多容易？因为归根结底，易用性才是让人能够快速解决问题的原因。而你的工具存在的意义就是为了解决问题。
Yeah, I would love your take on this, because I don't know how that all played out. It's a little bit, I'm definitely a user of TensorFlow and PyTorch. But sort of how did PyTorch kind of take the lead and leapfrog over everybody? You know, and I guess like, what were maybe some of the mistakes MXNet did or some of the gaps that PyTorch was able to fill that allowed them to do that yeah I think some of the things I observed and again I think there's definitely many more angles to it but the first thing I think is usability is the number one thing, right? And I think, especially for us as engineers, we tend to sometimes underrate usability thinking,
是的，我很想听听你对这件事的看法，因为我不知道整个过程是怎么演变的。我本人确实是 TensorFlow 和 PyTorch 的用户，但 PyTorch 究竟是如何取得领先并超越所有人的呢？你知道的，我想知道 MXNet 可能犯了哪些错误，或者 PyTorch 填补了哪些空白，才让他们做到了这一点。是的，我认为我观察到的一些情况是——当然这肯定还有很多其他角度——但最重要的一点我认为是易用性，对吧？而且我认为，特别是对我们工程师而言，我们有时往往会低估易用性，认为：
oh no, usability, you know, it's similar, right? Like people can achieve the same goal in different way. One way may be more complex than the other, but it's fine. Performance matters more. That's like a very common pitfall. And I think definitely, I think on MXNet side, we definitely fell into that pitfall where we optimize for performance rather than optimizing for usability. So I think that is one key learning. And I think every tool developer, platform developer, framework developer out there, I recommend always put
“哦，不，易用性这东西其实都差不多，对吧？就像人们可以用不同的方式达到相同的目标一样。一种方式可能比另一种更复杂，但没关系，性能更重要。”这是一种非常常见的误区。我想在 MXNet 方面，我们确实陷入了这个误区，我们优化的是性能，而不是易用性。所以我认为这是一个关键的教训。对于每一位工具开发者、平台开发者、框架开发者，我都建议永远把
usability as the most important thing. Performance, you can catch up later on. And actually for, you know, for people to get started, they actually don't look, usually they don't look too much into the performance. They would look more about the usability, how easy it is to onboard, how easy it is to learn, how easy is it to extend? How easy is it to apply it to kind of core problems? Because, you know, at the end of the day, usability is what allows, first of all, people to move quickly solving a problem. And your tool exists to solve a problem.
易用性放在最最重要的位置。性能以后是可以追赶上来的。而且实际上，对人们来说，在刚开始接触时，他们通常不会过分关注性能。他们会更看重易用性：上手有多简单，学习有多容易，扩展有多方便，将其应用于核心问题有多轻松？因为说到底，易用性才是让人们能够快速解决问题的关键，而你的工具存在的意义就是为了解决问题。
It doesn't exist for the soul of, you know, existing as a tool. And moving quickly actually saves tons of time and money. So I definitely say usability over performance. That's one key learning to keep in mind. Yeah, I think I actually, you know, if we follow that trail, follow that breadcrumb trail, and one of the things that Facebook did really well was having a lot of different roles inside the company.
它存在的灵魂并不是为了作为一种工具而存在。而且，快速行动实际上节省了大量的时间和金钱。所以我绝对会说易用性优于性能。这是需要记住的一个关键经验。是的，我觉得实际上，你知道，如果我们沿着那条线索、那条面包屑线索走下去，Facebook做得非常好的事情之一就是在公司内部设立了许多不同的角色。
You know, it wasn't just everyone was software engineer. And I think that that, although it seems esoteric, if you think about it, that really plays into this where if everyone's a software engineer and a software engineer is building things for other software engineers, then of course, why can't you use this really convoluted API? I did, and I'm a software engineer, right? But if you have, you know, research scientists, machine learning engineer, and then embedded engineer
你知道，并不是每个人都是软件工程师。我认为，尽管这看起来有点深奥，但如果你仔细想想，这确实符合这种情况：如果每个人都是软件工程师，而软件工程师又是为其他软件工程师构建东西，那么当然，你为什么不能使用这个非常复杂的API呢？我用了，而且我是一个软件工程师，对吧？但是如果你有，你知道，研究科学家、机器学习工程师以及嵌入式工程师
and software engineer, then, you know, it's more clear that like the machine learning engineer, the research scientist is the customer of something like PyTorch. And that you can't really expect,
和软件工程师，那么，你知道，就会更清楚地看到，机器学习工程师、研究科学家才是像PyTorch这样的工具的客户。你真的不能指望，
even though they have engineer in the title, you can't really expect them even though they have engineer in the title, you can't really expect them to figure out some weird C++ error. And so I think setting up that distinction early on kind of caused all these sort of downstream effects. Because I think if Amazon had treated the folks using MXNet as true customers instead of engineers,
尽管他们的头衔里有工程师，但你真的不能指望他们——尽管他们的头衔里有工程师，但你真的不能指望他们——去弄懂一些奇怪的C++错误。所以我觉得在早期建立这种区别，在某种程度上引发了所有这些下游效应。因为我认为，如果亚马逊把使用MXNet的人视为真正的客户而不是工程师，
Amazon is amazing at customer satisfaction, right? So it's almost like maybe that's where the issue kind of started, right? Yeah, yeah. That was definitely part of it. I think the other thing which you also alluded to is the importance of building a community. And actually building a community is definitely not trivial, requires deep thought. I'd say at the equivalent level to thinking through software design, for example, you want to think about how do you design your community? How do you design it so people, wherever they are,
亚马逊在客户满意度方面非常出色，对吧？所以这几乎就像是，也许问题就是从那里开始的吧？是的，是的。这绝对是其中的一部分。我认为另一件你刚才也提到的事情是构建社区的重要性。而且，构建社区绝对不是一件小事，它需要深入的思考。我想说，这相当于思考软件设计的水平，例如，你需要考虑如何设计你的社区？如何进行设计，以便人们无论身在何处，
they want to use the tool, they're well-supported, they have resources, they have people to follow. That also requires a lot of deep thought. When I look at the PyTorch, I think they definitely, I'm not sure if they did that from the beginning, but at some point they started investing a lot in that and I think they did it fantastically well. I think there is a real PyTorch community and I actually consider myself now part of the PyTorch community. You know, I spoke at their last, you know,
他们都想使用这个工具，他们能获得良好的支持，拥有资源，有可以追随的人。这同样需要大量的深入思考。当我看着PyTorch时，我认为他们绝对——我不确定他们是不是从一开始就这么做的，但在某个时候，他们开始在这方面投入巨资，而且我认为他们做得非常棒。我认为确实存在一个真正的PyTorch社区，我现在甚至认为自己是PyTorch社区的一部分。你知道，我在他们上一次的，你知道，
PyTorch developer conference. I met with a lot of people at MosaicML. You know, we are part of that community. And that community is what helps PyTorch be successful and more importantly, really be used by so many people in a really productive and constructive way. Yeah, that's a really good call out. Yeah, I agree 100%. I feel like I'm also part of that community. I think they did an amazing job with SEO.
PyTorch开发者大会上发过言。我在MosaicML遇到了很多人。你知道，我们是那个社区的一部分。正是这个社区帮助PyTorch取得了成功，更重要的是，让如此多的人真正以一种极具生产力和建设性的方式使用它。是的，这是一个非常好的点。是的，我100%同意。我觉得我也是那个社区的一部分。我觉得他们在SEO方面做得非常出色。
When you search Google for PyTorch issues, it'll take you to the PyTorch forum. I don't even know if there's a PyTorch stack overflow. I mean, I'm sure there is, but I don't know if there's a significant one. But they've done an amazing job of being the place where you go for issues and solutions. on their ML platform. And now you're at Mosaic, which is a startup kind of full circle. It's a startup here in the US, but a startup nonetheless. And can you kind of describe that? I mean, it feels a little scary. We talked about Amazon, the enormity of the business. AWS is one of the biggest businesses in the world.
当你在谷歌上搜索PyTorch的问题时，它会把你带到PyTorch论坛。我甚至不知道有没有PyTorch的Stack Overflow。我的意思是，我确信是有的，但我不知道有没有规模很大的那种。但他们做得非常出色，成为了你寻找问题和解决方案的首选之地。在他们的机器学习平台上。现在你在Mosaic，这是一家初创公司，有点像兜了个圈子。这是一家美国的初创公司，但不管怎样，它是一家初创公司。你能描述一下那种感觉吗？我的意思是，这感觉有点吓人。我们谈到了亚马逊，那庞大的业务。AWS是世界上最大的业务之一。
And so how do you kind of take that leap to Mosaic knowing kind of what you're up against? Yeah, so I think we missed another kind of station along the way, which is after AWS ML, I joined Facebook. Back then it was Facebook, today it's Meta. And I joined the Meta's AI team. And then I did a bunch of things over there that were a lot of fun, starting with the recommendation platform called Deeper back then, and then expanding also into foundation model services there for language understanding, image understanding, video understanding. I still remember, you know, Haggai and I worked together, and I still remember when Hag know, Hagai and I worked together and I still remember when Hagai first joined.
那么，面对你所面对的竞争，你究竟是如何下定决心跳槽到Mosaic的呢？是的，所以我觉得我们漏掉了沿途的另一个“站点”，那就是在AWS机器学习之后，我加入了Facebook。当时它叫Facebook，今天叫Meta。我加入了Meta的人工智能团队。然后我在那里做了一堆非常有趣的事情，从当时叫做Deeper的推荐平台开始，然后还扩展到那里的语言理解、图像理解、视频理解的基础模型服务。我还记得，你知道，Hagai和我一起工作，我仍然记得当Hag——你知道，Hagai和我一起工作，我仍然记得当Hagai刚加入的时候。
And I remember thinking, wow, this person has long hair. The guy had this really long hair. But total genius, a ton of respect. You've helped me a ton along the way. So I really do appreciate it. It's been a pleasure. It was a pleasure working with you. See, it was awesome.
我记得当时想，哇，这个人头发好长啊。这家伙留着这么长的头发。但绝对是个天才，非常令人尊敬。一路上你帮了我很多忙。所以我真的很感激。这真是一段美好的经历。和你共事很愉快。你看，这太棒了。
We did a bunch of cool AI stuff together. And I think you left after I did, I think, or maybe it was before. It was around the same time, though. A little bit after you did. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I really kind of really wanted to, after so many years in big tech companies and there's definitely
我们一起做了一些很酷的人工智能东西。我想你是在我之后离开的，我想，或者也许是在之前。不过大约是同一时间。比你稍微晚一点。是的。好的。是的，我真的很想，在大型科技公司待了这么多年之后——大型科技公司绝对
nothing wrong with big tech companies i think you learn a lot you do a lot you have really kind of your impact just you know propagates through you know these immense customer bases right that these companies have you know in a smaller company have more there, you feel like your impact is more direct and you do have more bandwidth and time to kind of do a zero to one thing, right? Like build something from scratch, solve a core problem with very kind of where it's more easy for you to see kind of full ownership or work with others, right? So I was really tingling for that. And then I, you know, so the opportunity with Mosaic ML, really loved the team, the folks there,
没有什么不对的地方，我认为你在那里能学到很多，做很多事，你的影响力真的会通过这些公司拥有的庞大客户群传播开来，对吧？但在一个小公司里，你在那里拥有更多，你会觉得你的影响力更直接，而且你有更多的带宽和时间来做从零到一的事情，对吧？比如从头构建某东西，用一种更容易让你看到完全所有权或与他人合作的方式来解决一个核心问题，对吧？所以我真的渴望那种感觉。然后我，你知道，所以MosaicML提供的机会，我真的很喜欢这个团队，那里的伙伴们，
really kind of felt good about the business problem. And I can tell you about that. And then just kind of, you know, decided to make the leap and join Mosaic ML. Got it. Cool. And that, is that the first time you started really diving into generative AI or did you do some of that at Facebook and Amazon? No, it was more at MosaicML.
对这个商业问题感觉很好。我可以跟你讲讲这个。然后就，你知道，决定迈出这一步，加入MosaicML。明白了。太酷了。那是你第一次真正深入涉足生成式人工智能，还是你在Facebook和Amazon时就做过一些这方面的工作？不，更多是在MosaicML。
I think even when I joined MosaicML, I don't even know, like the term generative AI was probably used back then, but not as often as it is used today. Right. Yep. So yeah, at MosaicML, the mission of MosaicML was really to, back then when I joined, it was, let's make machine learning more efficient. The reason for making it more efficient is that, you know, anybody can see the pace at which the complexity of training deep learning models is increasing.
我想甚至当我加入MosaicML时，我都不知道——“生成式人工智能”这个术语当时可能已经被使用了，但没有像今天这样频繁。对的。没错。所以是的，在MosaicML，MosaicML的使命真的是，自我加入时起，就是让机器学习变得更高效。之所以要让它更高效，是因为，你知道，任何人都能看到训练深度学习模型复杂性增加的速度。
And I think, by by the way that trend is actually toning down now we can get to it in a minute but you know if you look at even the last four years you know going from birth i think it was 2018 to gpt3 175 million parameters a couple of years later there's actually an there has been a growth in the number of model parameters of an order of magnitude every year, which is, it's just insane, right? And obviously, it requires much more compute and, you know, transformer architecture, because of the transformer blocks, it's quadratic in terms of the number of parameters. So, you know, that growth just kind of limited the number of companies, organizations out there that can actually leverage these advanced models just because it became much more expensive to train these models and, of course, also to deploy them.
顺便说一句，这种趋势现在实际上正在放缓，我们一会儿可以谈到这一点，但是，你知道，如果你看看过去四年，从BERT（我想是2018年）到几年后的GPT-3（拥有1750亿个参数），实际上模型参数的数量每年都在呈一个数量级地增长，这太疯狂了，对吧？显然，这需要更多的计算能力，而且Transformer架构，因为有Transformer块，在参数数量上是呈二次方增长的。所以，这种增长限制了能够真正利用这些先进模型的公司和组织的数量，仅仅是因为训练这些模型以及当然还有部署它们的成本变得非常高昂。
So Mosaic tried to initially to just make this more efficient so it's more accessible. As we built our product, which is the mosaic ml platform it's a platform for training and deploying these models i kind of realized that the problem space is more than just efficiency i would even say efficiency right is a feature but then there's a lot of other things that make these models less accessible you know it's the complexity of uh you know setting up the infrastructure it's the complexity of getting started with some baseline model. Again, going back to ease of use, right? How can this be made as easy as possible
因此，Mosaic最初试图让这变得更高效，从而更容易接近。当我们构建我们的产品——即MosaicML平台，这是一个用于训练和部署这些模型的平台时，我开始意识到问题空间不仅仅是效率，我甚至可以说效率只是一个特性，但还有很多其他东西让这些模型不那么容易接近，你知道，比如设置基础设施的复杂性，比如用一些基线模型入门的复杂性。再次回到易用性上来，对吧？如何才能让它尽可能简单，
so as many companies as possible can leverage this technology? And this is our focus now at Mosaic. It's just making state-of-the-art AI with a focus on generative AI accessible to any company out there, you know, not just kind of the usual suspects of the big technology companies or big labs like OpenAI or Google Research. Yeah, that makes sense. So, you know, I think generative AI might be at that point where, you know, an average person has heard the word but has no idea what it is, like, it's not defined
以便尽可能多的公司能够利用这项技术？这就是我们现在在Mosaic的重点。就是让最先进的人工智能（专注于生成式人工智能）对家喻户晓的公司来说都触手可及，你知道，不仅仅是大型科技公司或OpenAI或谷歌研究院等大型实验室的常客。是的，这说得通。所以，你知道，我认为生成式人工智能可能正处于这样一个阶段：平均水平的人听过这个词，但完全不知道它是什么，就像它没有被
for them. And so it's, it just occupies this sort of space, this soup of different things that they have seen and read about. And so this is a great time for us to really define it. Like, what is what is generative AI? And, you know, what's kind of the brief history there? Yeah, so I would say generative AI refers to, you know, AI technology and more specifically deep learning models that do a really incredible job generating media such as text or images or videos or audio through very simple prompts. And I think typically what we see today in something like, you know, a model like ChatGPT is, you know, you put in text, phrasing a request or a question,
为他们定义一样。所以它只占据了这样一种空间，一种他们见过和读过的各种事物的“大杂烩”。因此，现在对我们来说是真正定义它的好时机。比如，什么是生成式人工智能？以及，那里的简短历史是怎样的？是的，所以我想说，生成式人工智能指的是人工智能技术，更具体地说是深度学习模型，它们在通过非常简单的提示生成媒体（例如文本、图像、视频或音频）方面做得非常出色。我认为今天我们在类似ChatGPT这样的模型中所看到的通常是，你输入文本，表达一个请求或问题，
and the model does a really incredible job following through on your request. And then, of course, there's also the kind of another poster child in stable diffusion, where it's a text-to-image or text-plus-image-to-image model that just takes a simple natural language text prompt with a request to generate some visual and does an incredible job of generating that visual. So those are, you know, that's what generative AI is at its core. And I think we're just seeing the beginning of it, meaning these models will be much better at following through on your requests. Plus, they'll be able to generate very impressive additional, you know, mediums, right? And I think video is one such example where we're still early on in video generation, and we'll see much more impressive things come along. But you can even expand this further, right? I recently did a
然后模型在执行你的请求方面做得非常出色。当然，还有另一个典型代表——稳定扩散（Stable Diffusion），它是一个文本转图像或文本加图像转图像的模型，它只接受一个简单的自然语言文本提示以及生成某种视觉效果的请求，并且在生成该视觉效果方面做得非常出色。所以这些就是，这就是生成式人工智能的核心。我认为我们才刚刚看到它的冰山一角，这意味着这些模型在执行你的请求方面会变得更好。另外，它们还将能够生成非常令人印象深刻的附加媒介，对吧？我认为视频就是一个这样的例子，我们目前在视频生成领域还处于早期阶段，未来我们会看到更多令人印象深刻的事情出现。但你甚至可以进一步拓展这一点，对吧？我最近在波士顿的一个会议上做了
keynote at a conference in Boston. I spent a lot of time creating the slides. Like I had the idea of what I want to talk about, but then a lot of time was spent creating the slides. I can definitely see generative AI sooner than later actually generating the slides for me, doing a pretty good job at it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. One of the things that always really inspired me, but I didn't know where it was going, was unsupervised and self-supervised learning. I thought, and this this goes way way back
主题演讲。我花了很多时间制作幻灯片。比如我知道我想讲什么，但随后花了很多时间制作幻灯片。我绝对能看到生成式人工智能在不久的将来会为我生成幻灯片，而且做得相当不错。是的，这完全说得通。一直以来真正启发我、但我不知道它将走向何方的事物之一，是无监督和自监督学习。我认为，这可以追溯到很久很久以前，
i had this idea where and feel free to in the audience steal this idea i'd love for someone to actually build this but it was an idea where you would have sort of like a zombie game so you'd be you know it's very typical you fight the zombies there's an infestation you need to get the medical supplies whatever but but you would be you'd start on your in your own house so the idea is you know i would plug into google maps or one of these map services and so i would somehow render the game across the entire planet and so whenever someone played the game it would get their location from their phone. Actually, I guess Pokemon Go is kind of like this, isn't it? But you would play in your own house.
我当时有这样一个想法，观众们如果有兴趣可以拿去用，我很乐意看到有人真正把这个做出来。这个想法是这样的：你会有某种类似于僵尸游戏的东西，所以你会，你知道，这非常典型，你与僵尸战斗，发生了瘟疫，你需要获取医疗物资等等，但是你将从你自己的房子开始。所以这个想法是，你知道，我会接入谷歌地图或其中一个地图服务，然后我会以某种方式在整个星球上渲染这个游戏。因此，每当有人玩这个游戏时，它就会从他们的手机获取他们的位置。实际上，我猜《宝可梦GO》有点像这样，不是吗？但你是在你自己的家里玩。
The thing that I ran into was, you know, how could I figure out which buildings should have which supplies? And so I thought, well, I could, you know, I could scrape Wikipedia and scrape the Internet and I could try to figure out what I wanted ultimately was for not me for like just the computer to do the work to figure out, oh, if I sneak into this hospital, which is like a real hospital on Google Maps, that I would find medical supplies there. And if I sneak into a car dealership, I wouldn't find medical supplies. I would find gasoline or something. Right. dealership, I wouldn't find medical supplies, I would find gasoline or something, right. And so,
我遇到的问题是，你知道，我怎么能弄清楚哪些建筑应该有什么物资呢？所以我想，好吧，我可以，你知道，我可以抓取维基百科和互联网，我可以试着找出我最终想要的是什么——不是我去做，而是让计算机来做这项工作，弄清楚，“哦，如果我潜入这家医院，这在谷歌地图上是一家真正的医院，我就会在那里找到医疗物资。如果我潜入一家汽车经销店，我就找不到医疗物资。我会找到汽油之类的东西。”对的。汽车经销店，我找不到医疗物资，我会找到汽油之类的东西，对的。所以，
you know, rather than having some content, you know, human in the loop there, I wanted it all to just get rendered, right. And then that kind of led to learning about these embeddings where, where somebody has, you know, scanned all of the internet through Common Crawl or Wikipedia or these things. And they figured out the similarity between words. So you could actually see what's the similarity between hospital and medical kit. And that would be more similar than gas station and medical kit. And so you would use that to sort of generate your game here. And I found that to be, I mean, I never finished the project, but I found it to be just really inspiring how I created like the entire planet
与其在其中引入某种人类干预的内容，我希望这一切都能直接被渲染出来，对的。然后这引导我了解了这些“嵌入”（embeddings），即某人通过Common Crawl、维基百科或这些东西扫描了整个互联网。他们找出了词语之间的相似性。所以你实际上可以看出医院和医疗包之间的相似性。这会比加油站和医疗包更相似。因此你可以用它来生成你的游戏。我发现，——虽然我从未完成这个项目——但我发现它真的非常鼓舞人心，我是如何创建出像整个星球一样多的物资的，就像在这些建筑里一样。这只是那些真正令人满意的时刻之一。所以从那时起，我一直对这个很感兴趣。这其中有一种魔力。也许你可以稍微谈谈，你知道，这实际上是如何运作的呢？
worth of supplies, like in these buildings. And it just was one of these kind of really satisfying moments. And so ever since then, I've always been into that. And there's just something magical about that. Maybe you could talk a little bit about, you know, how does that actually work?
所以，当有人在使用Mosaic，或者在使用SageMaker（你也在那工作过）时，他们是如何构建这些巨型模型的？是的。所以MosaicML提供了一个平台，对吧，这是一个用于训练然后部署这些模型的平台。我可以先简单描述一下，当你，你知道，当有人想要训练这样一个模型，比如一个大语言模型（LLM）时，他们需要做什么，然后，你知道，一个平台如何真正帮助他们实现这一目标。通常，第一件事，它总是从定义任务开始，对吧？你正试图解决的任务。而且，你知道，外面肯定有很多通用的LLM，对吧？它们只是，你知道，它们的任务基本上是能够在商业层面上遵循指令、请求、问题，并且很好地回应人类在询问或提示的内容。
So, you know, when someone's on Mosaic or on, you know, SageMaker, which you also worked on, how do they build these giant models? Yeah. So Mosaic ML offers a platform, right, which is a platform for training and then deploying these models. I can start by maybe quickly describing, you know, when you are, you know, when someone wants to train such a model, let's say a large language model, LLM, what they need to do and then, you know, how a platform can actually help them achieve that. So typically, the first thing is it always starts with defining the task, right? You're trying to solve. And, you know, there's definitely a lot of general purpose LLMs out there, right? That just are, you know, their task is to basically be able to, on the business level, kind of be able to follow through on instructions, requests, questions, and do a good job responding to what a human is asking or prompting.
然后当你查看机器学习任务时，它基本上是下一个词的预测。因此，当您获得一系列输入的词（这是一个人类句子）时，预测下一个词，然后预测再下一个词，再下一个词。当你这样做很多次时，你就会得到一个连贯的响应。第一件事当然是，你知道，你需要弄清楚你的数据集、训练数据集，我刚才稍微略过了一些事情，当然它们相当复杂。然后是模型架构，它涵盖了诸如……你知道的，神经网络的架构，以及
And then when you look at the machine learning task, it's basically completion of the next word. So when you get an input sequence of words, which is a human sentence, complete the next word, and then complete the next word after that, and the next word after that. And when you do this a bunch of times you get a coherent response the first thing is of course you know you need to figure out your data set training data set and i kind of breeze through some things of course they're pretty complex but the data set then there's the model architecture which covers things like uh you know both the architecture of the neural network, and
我们今天总是为这些事情使用神经网络，还有模型的规模。因为使用相同的架构，你可以对其进行缩放，这意味着跨不同层的参数数量可以更大或更小。这对你需要的计算量和需要的数据量都有影响，我们一会儿会讨论这一点。然后你要设置训练方案，这意味着训练的超参数，以及你的评估。你将如何评估你的模型与你最初拥有的任务的对比？在那之后的下一步将是部署模型，一旦你拥有了一个好的模型，
we always use neural networks for these things today, as well as the scale of the model. Because with the same architecture, you can scale it, meaning the number of parameters across the different layers can be larger or smaller. It has implications on the compute you'll need and the amount of data you'll need, and we'll get to that in a minute. Then you want to set up your training regime, meaning the hyperparameters for training, as well as your evaluation. How are you going to evaluate your model versus the original task that you had? The next step after that is going to be deploying the model once you have a good model,
这几乎就像是一个相关的问题，但现在几乎是独立的。关于我所说的所有这些事情，需要注意的是这些模型的规模往往是……你知道的，非常大，并且……社区、行业发现的是，当你放大这些基于Transformer的架构时，你会得到所谓的“涌现行为”（emergent behavior），这意味着模型突然间能够像阶跃函数链一样，模型突然能够处理新问题——我的意思是，它没有明确针对这些问题进行优化，它们只是随着更大的模型规模和更多的数据而涌现出来。这方面的一个例子是解决数学问题的能力。我认为OpenAI及其GPT的工作和论文，谷歌与其名为Lambda的论文，都指出了其中一些涌现行为，包括解决数学问题，以及其他一些
and that's almost like a related problem, but but almost separate now what's important to note about all of these things that i've said is the the scale of these models tend to be uh you know very large and uh what we've what what i think the community the industry has found is that when you scale these transformer-based architecture up, you get what's called emergent behavior, meaning the model is suddenly, it's like a step function chain where the model is suddenly able to handle new problems that, I mean, it wasn't explicitly optimized for, and they just emerge with a bigger model size and more training data. One example for that is the ability to solve math problems. I think both OpenAI and their GPT work and paper, Google with their Lambda paper called out some of these emergent behaviors, including solving math problems, but other things as
行为。是的，值得一提的是要深入探讨规模。是的，我，你知道，当我开始对大语言模型产生兴趣时，我想，好吧，你有一个相当不错的GPU，我的意思是，它——我不知道，三四年前的，它有——我不知道，一吉字节的GPU显存什么的，我其实不知道它有多少，大约一到两吉字节。我心想，哦，我可以下载数据集自己训练一个模型。答案是——我会给在座的各位省点时间——你做不到。因为数据集太庞大了，模型太庞大了。即使你想微调模型，
well. Yeah, it's important to mention to double click on the scale yeah i you know when when i was getting interested in the large language models i thought well you have a pretty decent gpu i mean it's i don't know three or four years old it has i don't know one gigabyte of gpu memory or something i don't know actually how much it has on the order of one or two gigabytes and uh i thought oh i could just download the the data set and train a train a model myself and uh the answer is i'll save everyone in the audience some time you can't do this so the data set is enormous the models are enormous even if you want to fine tune the model
你仍然需要将它加载到内存中，我想他们说过你需要像60……基本上你需要一个价值两千美元的GPU如果你想自己做的话，这超出了我的预算；所以，嗯……所以，是的，你必须使用某种服务。我认为这可能是……你知道，也许有些计算机视觉模型是这样的，但对我和我而言，这是第一次你就是……你不能在家尝试这个。你可以在家里做，但你不能在自己的房子里做。是的，完全正确。所以，我的意思是，仅举几个例子，我的意思是，你知道，Meta发布了训练一个名为OPT175模型的成果，这是一个拥有1750亿个参数的模型。
you still have to load it into memory and i think they said you needed like 60 basically you need a gpu that costs two thousand dollars if you want to do this yourself which is uh out of my budget so um um so yeah you kind of have to use a service i think this might be the uh you know maybe some of the computer vision models were like this, but for me, at least this is the first time where you just, you can't try this at home. You can do it yourself, but you can't do it in your own house. Yeah, exactly. So, I mean, just to give a few examples, I mean, you know, Meta published results of training a model called OPT175, which is a 175 billion parameter model.
他们进行了训练——他们没有公布权重，但他们确实公布了日志和其他细节。它在数千个GPU上训练了一个多月，预算方面，这种操作可能会花费数百万美元。我甚至还没谈到之前的准备工作，之后的部署，仅仅是训练。对的。参数和权重是一回事吗？当人们说有70亿个参数时，那是70亿个权重吗？
They trained, they haven't published the weights, but they did publish a log book and other details. It was trained for over a month on thousands of GPUs and budget, that kind of operation can be in the millions of dollars. And I'm not even talking about preparation before, deploying after, just the training. Right. Is a parameter and a weight the same thing? When people say there's 7 billion parameters, is that 7 billion weights?
是的，通常人们就是这么称呼它的。所以它绝对是巨大的。虽然我认为我们在行业中了解到的是，你知道，发生了一些事情。所以我想首先，像OPT甚至GPT-3这样的模型，其实对它的体量来说训练不足，这意味着你实际上可以采用一个参数更少、用更多数据训练的更小型模型，它的表现实际上可以和用较少数据训练的更大模型一样好，甚至更好。现在，他们怎么知道的？他们是如何衡量的？
Yeah, usually that's how people refer to it. So it's definitely immense. Although I think what we're learning in an industry is that, you know, there has been a few things. So I think first of all, a model like OPT or even GPT-3, it was actually under-trained for its size, meaning you can take an actually a smaller model with less parameters, train it on more data, and it will actually perform just as well or even better than a bigger model trained on less data. Now, how do they know that? How do they measure that?
是的，OpenAI发表过一篇论文。我想人们倾向于称之为“奇趣蛋”论文（chinchilla paper）。我只是记不清这篇论文的确切名称了。我认为我们社区在选择模型名称和论文名称时有着非常好的幽默感。对的，都是动物，对吧？有美洲驼、羊驼、考拉。是的，但是，是的，所以奇趣蛋论文基本上谈论的是缩放定律（scaling laws），这意味着对于给定的——这一切都是关于，你知道，都参考了非常相似的架构。
Yeah, so there's a paper published by Open Mind. I think people tend to refer to it as a chinchilla paper. I just don't remember the exact name of the paper. I think our community is having a really good sense of humor when choosing model names and paper names. Right, it's all animals, right? There's llama, alpaca, koala. Yeah, but yeah, so the chinchilla paper basically talks about the scaling laws, meaning for a given, it's all about, you know, all referring to very similar architecture.
也就是基于Transformer的架构和不同的模型大小，数据量是多少？通常这被计算为将模型训练到满负荷所需的token数量。现在他们采用的方式，没有什么花哨的数学分析。不幸的是，我认为机器学习在某种程度上仍然更像是炼金术而不是科学。所以他们做的是只进行了一堆实验，
So transformer-based architecture and then different model sizes, what's the amount of data? And typically that's counted as number of tokens that are required to train it to its full capacity. Now the way they, there is no fancy math kind of analysis. Unfortunately, I think machine learning is somewhat still feels more like alchemy than science. So what they do is just train a bunch of experiments
采用了相同的架构，用不同的大小的数据集进行了训练，然后测量了各种评估指标，并在此基础上做出了他们的分析。他们能够训练——我想那是一个拥有600亿参数的模型，使用的token数量我记不清了——它的表现超越了拥有1750亿参数的GPT-3的评估指标。所以尽管参数数量是OpenAI大模型的三分之一，
and just took the same architecture, train it in different data sizes, data set sizes, and then measured the various evaluation metrics and then kind of came up with their analysis. And they were able to train, I think it was a 60 billion parameter model on, I don't remember how many tokens, and it outperformed the valuation metrics of GPT-3 with 175 billion parameter. So although the number of parameters was a third of OpenAI's big model,
但这个小模型实际上表现得比大模型更好。哦，有趣。是的。所以我想每天都有新的东西被发现。我可以告诉你，我举两个我们在MosaicML的客户的例子。一个是Replit。所以Replit是一个非常受欢迎的在线IDE。我相信听众们至少有些人是熟悉的。
the smaller model actually outperformed the bigger one. Oh, interesting. Yeah. So I think there's new kind of things being discovered by the day. I can tell you that I give example of two of our customers at Mosaic ML. One is Replit. So Replit is kind of very popular online IDE. I'm sure the listeners, some of them at least are familiar.
对于那些不熟悉的人，一定要去看看。Replit是一个面向软件开发人员的 fantástico（太棒了）工具。他们构建了他们的代码助手，对吧，叫做Ghostwriter。而且，你知道，它做的事情相当酷，让开发人员的效率大大提高，比如，你知道，代码补全，你知道，它可以根据注释创建函数，它可以为你解释代码等等，所以它真的是一个很好的工具。它背后的模型是在MosaicML平台上训练的，这是一个30亿参数的模型，你知道，你“引号引号”只用了30亿——有趣的是，今天30亿被认为是一个小模型，就在几年以前，它还被认为是个庞然大物。但这个30亿参数的模型是在大约5000亿token的纯代码、开源代码上训练出来的。有没有一个常见的地方我可以获取所有GitHub的抓取数据或者类似的东西？
And for those that don't, definitely check it out. Replit is a fantastic tool for software developers. They built their code assistant, right, called Ghostwriter. And, you know, it does things that are pretty cool, making developers much more productive, like, you know, code completion, you know, it can create functions from comments it can explain your code for you etc so it's really a nice tool the model behind it was trained on mosaic ml platform it's a three billion parameter model uh you know only you quote quote unquote only three billion it's funny today three billion considered a small model just a couple of years ago, it was considered huge. But 3 billion parameter model trained on, I think, about 500 billion tokens of just code, open source code. Is there a common place where I could get a scrape of all of GitHub or something?
你是如何获得如此多的代码token的？是的，有很多数据集。我想它叫做The Stack。那是一个你可以访问的开源数据集。Replit本身，显然，因为人们已经，你知道，在使用它们，他们存储了大量的代码。他们可以访问其中的一部分。当然，前提是编写该代码的人允许Replit使用它。所以，是的。所以肯定有很多特定数据集。此外，你往往还会进行混合，对吧？通常——这就是炼金术发挥作用的地方，对吧？通常你想混合你的训练数据集，
How do you get that many tokens of code? Yeah, there are a lot of datasets. I think it's called the stack. That's an open source dataset that you can access. Replit itself, obviously, because people have, you know, using them for, you know, they store a lot of code. They have access to some of that. Of course, when the writers of that code allowed Replit to use it. So, yeah. So there's definitely a lot of kind of specific data sets. Plus, you also tend to mix, right? So usually, and that's where the alchemy part comes in, right? Usually you want to mix your training data set
使其更加平衡。所以，你知道，你想混合一点来自维基百科或其他网站的自然语言，因为你知道，即使是代码注释，例如，它们，你知道，它们是用通俗英语写的，它们不是用C++或任何其他编程语言写的，所以人们倾向于进行混合。顺便说一句，Replit发表了一篇非常棒的博客文章，讲述了他们是如何构建那个模型的。里面有很多细节，包括建模方面、
so it's a bit balanced. So, you know, you want to mix a little bit of kind of natural natural language from you know wikipedia or other websites because you know even code comments for example they're you know they're written in plain english they're not written in c plus plus or whatever other programming language so people tend to do mixing by the way replete published a fantastic blog post talking about how they built that model. And there's a lot of details there, including both the modeling side,
数据集管理方面以及基础设施。但回到TLDR（简而言之），所以它是一个相对较小的模型，专门用于充当代码助手。它实际上击败了比它大两到三倍的OpenAI Codex。这就是那个模型——OpenAI Codex是GitHub Copilot背后的模型。所以我想有趣的是，首先，你知道，一个相对较小的公司——我的意思是，Replit是一家初创公司。
data set management side, as well as the infrastructure. But just going back to kind of the TLDR, so it was a relatively small model, specialized for being a code assistant. And it actually outperformed the, I think, two or three times larger OpenAI Codex. And that's the model, OpenAI Codex is the model behind GitHub Copilot. So I think what's interesting there is, first of all, you know, a relatively small company, I mean, Replit is a startup.
它是一家大型初创公司。它仍然是一家初创公司。它是一家大型初创公司。它仍然是一家初创公司。它能够训练出一个比另一个模型更小的模型，并且在相当多的评估指标上表现优于它。而且他们能够用一个相当小的团队做到这一点。是的，这太惊人了。我认为你在那里触及了许多不同的事情。所以有一件事是，你知道，人们绝对应该熟悉在云端做事情。我们已经在许多节目中谈论过这一点，我们邀请过嘉宾，就在几集前我们刚刚做了一期关于Kubernetes的节目。所以你可以，你手头肯定会有很多工具，
It's a big startup. It's still a startup. It's a big startup. It's still a startup. Was able to train a model smaller than another model, as well as outperforming it on quite a few evaluation metrics. And we're able to do it with actually quite a small team. Yeah, that's amazing. I think you touched on so many different things there. So one thing is, you know, folks should definitely get familiar with doing things on the cloud. And we've talked about this for many shows, we've had folks, we literally just had a show on Kubernetes a few episodes ago. And so you kind of, you'll definitely have a lot of tools at your disposal,
它们会抽象掉一层又一层的这些东西。但熟悉在云端运行程序是个好主意，因为把一个5000亿token的数据集存储在你的桌面上，大概是不可能的。而且绝对还有那些模型，其资本成本会失控。而且很多学生，如果你在上大学或高中，你知道，通常你可以获得一大堆不同的亚马逊额度以及各种各样的服务。是的，完全是这样。然后听起来，如果你说，你知道，“我是一个音乐家，我想……在一个模型上训练所有的……其实音乐我们在这里讨论过，这里还有一个更不一样的。我对戏剧真的很感兴趣，我想把莎士比亚时代的所有英文戏剧都输入到某个大语言模型中。”第一步是找到那个数据集。
which will abstract away, you know away layer upon layer of this. But it's good to kind of get familiar with running things on the cloud because storing a 500 billion token data set on your desktop, probably out of the question. And definitely the models, it would just the capital cost would get out of control and a lot of students you know if you're in college or high school you know often there's a whole bunch of different amazon credits that you can get and all sorts of services there yeah totally yeah and then it sounds like the the process for you know if you say you know i'm a musician and i want to uh train a model on you know all of these uh actually music we talked about here's an even different one. I'm really into theater and I want all of the English plays around Shakespeare's era all ingested into some large language model. Step one is to find that data set.
所以听起来我通常会做的——Hagai，我也很想听听你在这方面的建议——但我通常只是把我想找的东西打到谷歌里，然后在末尾加上“数据集”这个词，看看是不是已经有人做过了。你有什么获取数据的技巧吗？我认为一个很好的起点是Hugging Face Hub。他们有数据集，那里的代码库，而且实际上有很多。
And so it sounds like what I usually do, and Hagar, I'd love to get your advice on this too, but I usually just type what I want and then add the word data set at the end into Google and try to see if someone's already done this. Do you have any tips for getting access to data? I think a great place to start would be Hugging Face Hub. They have a data set, repositories there, and a lot of them, actually.
实际上，问题在于从众多的可用选项中选择正确的那一个。但Hugging Face Hub是一个很好的起点。同样地，顺别说一句，对于从模型架构开始也是如此。所以好的一点是，在这一点上，你不需要从头开始做任何事情。有可用的数据集，有可用的模型，还有大量的训练配方。
Actually, the problem is choosing the right one out of so many available. But Hugging Face Hub is a great place to start. Similarly, by the way, for starting with the model architecture. So the nice thing is is at this point, you don't have to do anything from scratch. There are data sets available, there are models available, and then there's a lot of training recipes available.
最好的入门方法就是从一个行之有效的东西开始，然后对其进行黑客修改（hacking it），对吧，以适应你的特定需求等。调整数据集的混合，调整你训练模型的任务。这实际上让我想到了一个观点，你知道，甚至退一步讲，你知道，人们如何利用生成式人工智能，或者更具体地说，你知道，例如大语言模型。
And the best way to get started is just to start with something that is working and then hacking it, right, to fit your specific needs, etc. You know, tweaking the dataset mix, tweaking the task you're training your model for. That actually kind of brings me to a point where, you know, even taking a step back, you know, how can people leverage generative AI or even being more specific, you know, large language models, for example.
我们刚才一直在讨论训练你自己的模型，我认为现在它确实变得容易多了，但它仍然——甚至当我看看我们刚才讨论过的Replit时，你知道，训练那个模型，Replit的模型花费了大约500个GPU运行了大约10天。哦，哇。是的。训练那个模型，Replit的模型花费了大约500个GPU运行了大约10天。哦，哇。是的。
We've been talking about kind of training your own model a little bit now, and I think it's definitely, it's gotten much easier today, but it's still, you know, even when I look at, you know, Replit, which we just discussed, right, training that model, Replit's model took about 500 GPUs running for about 10 days. Oh, wow. Yeah. that model replitz model took about 500 gpus running for about 10 days oh wow yeah so you know for those of us that are familiar with efforts at google and facebook it sounds you know like something relatively small and fast and definitely it is comparing to the bigger things that have been happening but then if you approach it from the perspective of, you know, maybe a much smaller company or even just someone who just wants to do a cool project, a student or just someone
所以，对于我们这些熟悉谷歌和Facebook工作的人来说，这听起来像是某种相对较小且快速的事情，与正在发生的更大事情相比，它绝对是这样的。但如果你从……的角度来接近它，你知道，也许是一家小得多的公司，或者仅仅是一个想做一个酷项目的人，一个学生或者只是一个在业余时间
doing a cool project on the side, that's definitely still big and requires a lot of, right, monetary investment. Yeah. But there are other ways to actually get started with LLMs that are much faster and cheaper. And we can maybe talk about those as well yeah i think uh we'll definitely dive into that going back to something you said earlier i do feel like it's very alchemic at the moment and and i think the reason for that if you think about what actually i want to say standardized or what took us to the next level in in chemical alchemy was just the reproducibility
做一个酷项目的人，那绝对还是很大的，需要大量的，对吧，资金投入。是的。但还有其他方法可以开始使用LLM，这些方法要快得多，也便宜得多。我们也许也可以谈谈这些方法。是的，我想……我们一定会深入探讨这一点。回到你之前说过的话，我确实觉得它目前非常具有炼金术的色彩，而且我认为原因在于，如果你想想在化学炼金术中，实际上是什么可以说是使之标准化或将我们带到下一个水平的，那就是可重复性
and the affordability of experiments. So people could run just thousands of experiments, do them in parallel in very sanitized environments. If we go to that factory in China, we'll have to wear those suits where we can't get any dust anywhere. And so everything has been extremely sanitized and as a result, just very reproducible. And so that's ultimately what turned alchemy from alchemy into chemistry. And so here, you're totally right. It's not only that it took those 500 machines for four days, but it's that it's probably their 20th or 30th model. So it's their 20th time dropping, you know, $2,000 to train this model. And they're constantly altering the data and mixing with it and hyperparameter tuning and all of that. So totally agree. I think, you know, very, very hard.
和实验的负担得起性。所以人们可以进行成千上万的实验，在高度消毒的环境中并行进行。如果我们去中国的那家工厂，我们必须穿上那些让我们不能沾染任何灰尘的衣服。所以一切都经过了极度消毒，因此具有极高的可重复性。这最终是将炼金术变成化学的东西。所以在这里，你完全说得对。不仅它动用了那500台机器四天，而且这可能是他们的第20个或第30个模型。所以这是他们第20次投入，你知道，2000美元来训练这个模型。他们一直在修改数据、进行混合、超参数调优以及所有这些。所以完全同意。我认为，你知道，非常非常难。
You know, it's a big investment to train one of these from scratch. And so that's, I guess, where fine tuning and other things come in. And what have you seen kind of on that front? Yeah. So, you know, I think two other alternatives that people, approaches people are taking that are slower, you know, have a lower barrier of entry or easier to get started. One is just using a model behind an API. And OpenAI is, I think,
从头开始训练其中一个模型是一笔巨大的投资。所以我想，这就是微调和其他事情派上用场的地方。你在这一方面看到了什么？是的。所以，你知道，我认为人们正在采用的另外两种替代方案、方法是较慢的，你知道，进入门槛较低或更容易上手。一种是只使用API背后的模型。而OpenAI是，我认为，
one service that is very broadly used already today where basically it's very easy to get started. You just sign up with the service, get an API key, and then you have access to a really powerful general purpose model, you know, and what's nice is to have access to that capacity. All you need to do is kind of just write an API call and, you know, whatever is your favorite programming language, but it's fairly simple and you don't need to know anything about machine learning.
今天已经得到非常广泛使用的一项服务，基本上它非常容易上手。你只需注册该服务，获取一个API密钥，然后你就可以访问一个功能非常强大的通用模型，你知道，好的一点是可以访问该容量。你所需要做的就是编写一个API调用，你知道，无论你最喜欢什么编程语言，但它相当简单，你不需要了解任何关于机器学习的知识。
But still, you have that power, that capacity. That's one good way to get started, especially to create prototypes, right? Or to play around with the technology and understand what it's capable of. Yeah, to that point, there's a lot you can do with engineering the prompt. I have a project that I'm working on with OpenAI and, you know, it was giving me answers that were not unreasonable, but didn't fit the product that I was trying to build.
但你仍然拥有那种力量，那种容量。这是一个很好的入门方法，特别是用于创建原型，对吧？或者试玩这项技术并了解它的功能。是的，说到这一点，通过提示工程（prompt engineering）你可以做很多事情。我有一个正在与OpenAI合作的项目，你知道，它给我的答案并非不合理，但不适合我试图构建的产品。
And I kind of found that by, you know, playing around with the prompt. One of the tricks I found is you can kind of if you know the beginning of the answer, so if you know, for example, it should start with answer colon or a person's name colon or the answer is, if you actually write that, it makes a huge, huge difference because it massively narrows the scope. So for example, I would ask a question, and this is actually, I wasn't using OpenAI at this point, I was using Lama,
我发现通过，你知道，摆弄提示。我发现的一个技巧是你可以——如果你知道答案的开头，所以如果你知道，例如，它应该以“回答：”开头，或者“人名：”开头，或者“答案是”，如果你真的写了那个，会产生巨大、巨大的差异，因为它极大地缩小了范围。例如，我会问一个问题——实际上，我当时没有使用OpenAI，我使用的是Llama。
which is the Facebook's open source LLM. So I asked a question, and then it generated another question, and then another question, and another question. I was like, no, I want you to answer the question. And so I found it as simple as putting your answer colon at the end of my question sentence, told it that it's expecting an answer. And so to your point, even before you try anything with gradients and loss functions and all of that, just playing around with something like OpenAI's model or any model as a service can teach you about the problem you're trying to solve. Exactly. Yeah. And I think the prompt engineering is definitely another kind of field of alchemy,
也就是 Facebook 开源的大语言模型。所以我问了一个问题，然后它生成了另一个问题，接着又是一个问题，再一个问题。我当时想，不对，我要你回答问题。所以我发现，只要在我的问题句子末尾加上“回答：”这么简单，就能告诉它它在期待一个回答。所以正如你所说，甚至在你尝试使用梯度、损失函数以及所有这些东西之前，单单玩一玩像 OpenAI 的模型或任何作为服务的模型，就能教给你很多关于你试图解决的问题的知识。完全正确。是的。而且我认为提示词工程绝对是另一种炼金术，
if you like it, but it today does have a really massive impact on the quality of responses you get from text completion. And I think an important thing to remember, I do think that folks who, you know, understand how the sausage is made are the best prompt engineers out there. Although there's definitely, you know, I think if you just Google prompt engineering today, you already see a lot of interesting kind of examples in Google to get started with.
如果你喜欢的话，但它今天对你从文本补全中获得的回答质量确实有着非常巨大的影响。我认为有一件重要的事情要记住，我确实认为那些（你知道的）了解香肠是怎么做出来的人，才是最顶尖的提示词工程专家。尽管肯定有（你知道的），我想如果你今天去谷歌搜索提示词工程，你已经能在谷歌上看到很多有趣的那种入门示例了。
But one important thing to remember when you are creating your prompt is, remember these models are typically trained with next word completion, right? So it's the auto-aggressive transformer models. They just try to predict the next word. So if you are giving them the beginning of the answer, for example, you already really made the problem much simpler for them, right? Because they don't have to guess your intent and get it right.
但当你创建提示词时，有一件重要的事情要记住，那就是记住这些模型通常是经过下一个词预测训练的，对吧？所以它们是自回归的 Transformer 模型。它们只是试图预测下一个词。因此，如果你给它们提供答案的开头，例如，你实际上就已经把它们的问题简化了很多，对吧？因为它们不必去猜你的意图并猜对。
You are indicating your intent to them by giving them the first few words of their answer. So that's a great way to squeeze better results out of them. I would say that personally, I expect this thing to matter less and less because models will be just much better at understanding your intent, maybe even better than we are at some point. Yep. It's definitely getting there. And the other interesting trend
你通过给出它们答案的前几个词，向它们表明了你的意图。所以这是一种从它们那里压榨出更好结果的好方法。我个人想说，我认为这件事会变得越来越不重要，因为模型将更擅长理解你的意图，也许在某些时候甚至比我们还要好。是的。它绝对正在朝着那个方向发展。另一个有趣的趋势
that is also pushing things in that way is what's called instruction fine-tuning. So my guess would be that maybe with the Lama model you played with, it was the base Lama and not an instruction fine-tuned version of Lama. Right, it was just the naive stock vanilla. Yeah. And with instruction fine-tuned version of Lama. Right, it was just the naive stock vanilla. Yeah, and with instruction fine-tuning, what people do is they take a base model. You know, Lama is pretty good. They have multiple sizes, but it's a pretty good model
也在推动事情朝着这个方向发展，那就是所谓的指令微调。所以我的猜测是，也许你玩的那个 Llama 模型，它是基础的 Llama，而不是经过指令微调版本的 Llama。没错，它只是最初级的、原汁原味的原始版本。是的。而通过指令微调版本的 Llama。没错，它只是最初级的、原汁原味的原始版本。是的，通过指令微调，人们做的是拿一个基础模型。你知道，Llama 相当不错。它们有多种尺寸，但它是一个相当不错的模型
overall. Yeah, I think I could only fit the 7 billion on my computer. Yeah, that would have been my guess. But then they fine-tuned that model to follow instructions. And then this means this model, you know, yeah, just has seen a lot of example of an instruction and a response to that instruction. And it's now that it can do a better job following instructions. And then, you know, assuming... How does that work?
总体而言。是的，我想我的电脑只能塞得下 70 亿参数的版本。是的，我本来也会这么猜。但接着他们对那个模型进行了微调，让它去遵循指令。这意味着这个模型（你知道的）嗯，刚刚见过大量关于指令以及对该指令的响应的示例。现在它能更好地完成遵循指令的工作了。然后，（你知道的）假设……这是怎么运作的？
Like, how does the system know that the question is finished? Like, how do they actually do that fine-tuning? Yeah, so typically, again, there's the art of how you format your data set. So typically, if you look at the instruction fine-tune, most instruction fine-tune data sets, they'll have sort of a structure of instruction, colon, some instruction text, and then response, colon, and some text around that. Sometimes people use also like hashes to kind of written, the model kind of has an easier time, right, to follow your instruction. Does this make sense?
比如，系统怎么知道问题已经结束了？比如，他们到底是怎么做那个微调的？是的，所以通常来说，这里面同样有关于你如何格式化数据集的艺术。所以通常，如果你看指令微调，大多数指令微调数据集，它们都会有一种结构，比如“指令：”，后面跟一些指令文本，然后是“响应：”，再周围是一些文本。有时人们还会使用像哈希符号之类的好让编写的内容让模型更容易理解，对吧，从而更容易遵循你的指令。这说得通吗？
Yeah, this makes sense. Actually, you know, this, this, I don't want to take this on too much of a tangent, but how do you deal with if most of the data is just crawled off the internet? How do people deal with all the HTML and the markup? I mean, if you're reading the New York Times and they italicize something, how does that get into the model? Yeah, so there's different approaches. I mean, some models, you actually want them to be able to generate HTML, right? I'll put that aside for a minute. Let's assume for a minute you want your model only to be able to write text. So when you curate your training data set, you filter out things like HTML tags, markdown formats, and stuff like that.
是的，这说得通。其实（你知道的），这个，我不想把话题扯得太远，但如果绝大多数数据都是从互联网上爬取下来的，你们是怎么处理的？人们是怎么处理所有的 HTML 和标记的？我的意思是，如果你在读《纽约时报》，他们把某些东西斜体化了，那怎么进到模型里去呢？是的，所以有不同的方法。我的意思是，有些模型，你其实希望它们能够生成 HTML，对吧？我先把这个放一边。我们假设有一分钟你想让你的模型只能写文本。所以当你策划你的训练数据集时，你要过滤掉像 HTML 标签、Markdown 格式之类的内容。
So your model only gets the text data and doesn't see anything else. That makes sense. Yeah. For some models, you do want them to create HTML. In that case, you do want to preserve that. Right. But again, your dataset should not only understand HTML, but also understand kind of the context of, you know, now you're asked to generate HTML and, or now you want to generate Python
这样你的模型就只能获取文本数据，而看不到其他任何东西。这就说得通了。是的。对于某些模型，你确实希望它们创建 HTML。在这种情况下，你确实希望保留这些内容。对的。但同样，你的数据集不仅应该理解 HTML，还应该理解（你知道的）上下文，即现在你被要求生成 HTML，或者现在你想生成 Python
code. And then instruction fine tuning is really helpful at explaining to the model that, hey, for a given response, it's expected to generate the distributions that are more, you know, text distributions or Python code or whatnot. Got it. And so I've seen this thing called LoRa. Is that, that seems pretty pivotal, like the low rank stuff seems pretty pivotal to the fine-tuning. What's the sort of connection there? Is instruction fine-tuning?
代码。然后指令微调对于向模型解释非常有用，嘿，对于给定的响应，它期望生成的分布更多是（你知道的）文本分布或 Python 代码之类的内容。明白了。我见过一个叫 LoRa 的东西。那是，那似乎相当关键，像低秩这样的东西对于微调似乎相当关键。那里的某种联系是什么？是指令微调吗？
How does that actually work? Yeah, so I'm definitely not an expert in LoRa, and I think it's also still pretty early days. But with LoRa, the idea is that you can do fine-tuning much more efficiently by decomposing matrices, and then your fine- is more efficient but then you can also apply you can take a base model and apply fine tuning by just uh you know applying the factorized matrices you got from from laura but is that is that the common thing so if someone
那到底是怎么运作的？是的，所以我绝对不是 LoRa 的专家，而且我认为这仍然处于早期阶段。但对于 LoRa，其想法是你可以通过分解矩阵来更高效地进行微调，然后你的微调会更高效，但随后你也可以应用——你可以拿一个基础模型，然后仅通过（你知道的）应用你从 LoRa 得到的因式分解矩阵来应用微调。但这，这是一种常见做法吗？所以如果有人
let's say someone out there wants to fine tune a model let's continue with the screenwriting example. So someone takes Llama off the internet and they want to adapt it to screenwriting. And let's say they've found the screenwriting data set and somehow they've converted it to Markdown or they've stripped out all the HTML. So they have the screenwriting data, they have the Facebook model. How would they, you know, either using Mosaic or using something else, like how would they actually fine tune that? Is there a module that everyone uses or something? Yeah. So what you would typically do, first of all, you know, curate that data set with, you know, basically we just text. So in this case, let's say it's screenwriting. So what
比方说，如果有人想微调一个模型，让我们继续以编剧为例。所以有人从互联网上拿了 Llama，他们想把它改编成编剧。比方说，他们找到了编剧数据集，不知怎么的，他们把它转换成了 Markdown，或者他们去掉了所有的 HTML。所以他们有了编剧数据，他们有了 Facebook 的模型。他们会如何（你知道的），无论是使用 Mosaic 还是使用别的什么，他们究竟会如何微调那个模型？有没有什么模块是每个人都在用的，或者是别的什么？是的。所以你通常会做的，首先（你知道的），策划那个数据集，基本上（你知道的）只有文本。所以在这种情况下，比方说是编剧。所以
people would typically do, they'll curate a data set that includes a lot of examples of screenplays, text, and then they would take a base model that was pre-trained on general purpose language. So that model should be pretty good at English, grammar, syntax, and understanding various concepts and all of that. But then that pre-trained model, they will just continue a training regime with that data set that they have. So they would fine tune it on that data.
人们通常会做的是，他们会策划一个数据集，其中包括大量剧本、文本的示例，然后他们会采用一个在通用语言上预训练过的基础模型。所以那个模型应该在英语、语法、句法以及理解各种概念等方面相当不错。但随后，对于那个预训练模型，他们将使用他们拥有的数据集继续进行训练。所以他们会根据这些数据对其进行微调。
Now we're not even getting into LoRa. LoRa is more like a way to do this in a more optimal manner, both for the fine tuning and applying that fine tune. I'll put that aside for a minute. There's a much more simple thing to do is just to take that data set you created and then just continue training the pre-trained model with that data. And what it will, it will kind of force the model's parameter to be better tuned for that kind of text, that kind of language.
现在我们甚至还没有涉及 LoRa。LoRa 更像是一种以更优化方式进行这一操作的方法，既适用于微调，也适用于应用该微调。我先把这个放一边。有一个更简单的事情要做，就是拿到你创建的数据集，然后继续用这些数据训练预训练模型。它所做的是，它会强制模型的参数更好地适应那种文本、那种语言。
At Mosaic, we recently... The other thing I would say is that it's also much cheaper and faster than the pre-training, because for the pre-training, you need to train it right on billions or even trillions of tokens. At Mosaic ML, we recently open sourced a model called MPT7B, so 7 billion parameters. It was trained on 1 trillion tokens of text, of language, which is huge. And this, you know, it cost us about $200,000 to train this model, this size on this number of tokens. But then to fine tune it on, we did an instruction fine tuned version, a chat fine tuned version, as well as a model that is able to actually write books or write stories, write fiction. that was much, much cheaper and much faster.
在 Mosaic，我们最近……我要说的另一件事是，它也比预训练便宜得多、快得多，因为对于预训练，你需要在数十亿甚至数万亿个 Token 上对它进行训练。在 Mosaic ML，我们最近开源了一个名为 MPT-7B 的模型，也就是 70 亿参数。它是在 1 万亿个文本、语言 Token 上训练的，这非常巨大。而这（你知道的），训练这个尺寸、这个 Token 数量的模型花费了我们大约 20 万美元。但随后为了对其进行微调，我们做了一个指令微调版本、一个聊天微调版本，以及一个能够真正写书、写故事、写小说的模型，那要便宜得多、快得多。
Like just to give you some data around that, it's all published in our blog post, but the base model took us about 10 days on 440 A100 GPUs. It's almost the best gpus out there except for the h100s just coming up so it costs us about two hundred thousand dollars so so so those 400 gpus for four days for 10 days oh 10 days okay so 400 so that's a 4000 GPU days cost $200,000. Yeah, it's not cheap. Yeah, yeah, it's definitely not cheap. But luckily, we've open sourced it with the weight. So anyone can build on top of it. Now, how does that work? Do they need your PyTorch code? They would, right? Yeah. So the PyTorch code is defining the model architecture. So that code has been open sourced,
为了给你提供一些相关的数据，这些都发表在我们的博客文章中，但基础模型在 440 个 A100 GPU 上花了我们大约 10 天时间。这几乎是市面上最好的 GPU，除了即将推出的 H100 之外，所以它花费了我们大约 20 万美元。所以，所以，所以那 400 个 GPU 运行 4 天，运行 10 天？哦，10 天，好的。所以 400 个，那是 4000 个 GPU 天，花费 20 万美元。是的，这不便宜。是的，是的，这绝对不便宜。但幸运的是，我们连同权重一起开源了它。所以任何人都可以基于它进行构建。现在，这到底是怎么运作的？他们需要你们的 PyTorch 代码吗？他们需要的，对吧？是的。所以 PyTorch 代码定义了模型架构。所以这些代码已经被开源了，
obviously. But there's, you know, and it is, there are a bunch of optimizations we'd put in there, but, you know, it's PyTorch code, a little bit of C++ for some of the optimized operators, but that's it. And then there's the weights itself, which is typically stored in a separate file, but then, you know, it's just PyTorch weight.
很明显。但（你知道的），而且它有，我们在那里投入了一堆优化，但（你知道的），它是 PyTorch 代码，还有一点点用于某些优化算子的 C++，就是这样。然后是权重本身，它通常存储在单独的文件中，但随后（你知道的），它只是 PyTorch 权重。
So we have example code, but basically once you instantiate the class for your model, you just use the standard PyTorch interface to load the parameters into the model. Yeah, getting kind of going full circle, you know, computer vision, we've been doing this for a while where, you know, you have a trunk model and then you have a bunch of heads for that model one head detects um you know traffic lights another head detects pedestrians stuff like that and so um it's well-traveled ground there i wonder how data efficient it is
所以我们有示例代码，但基本上，一旦你实例化了模型的类，你就只需使用标准的 PyTorch 接口将参数加载到模型中。是的，这有点兜了一个圈子（你知道的），计算机视觉，我们已经这样做有一段时间了，（你知道的）你有一个骨干模型，然后你为该模型准备了一堆头部，一个头部检测（你知道的）交通灯，另一个头部检测行人，诸如此类。所以……这是一个走过很多弯路、非常成熟的领域，我想知道它的数据效率有多高？
i guess there's no way to really know right you you try to amp up the learning rate but but there's not really a scientific way to say okay this is how many playwright scripts you need to have a model that's reasonable it's like one of these things it's like really hard to calculate it's really hard yes it's still more of empirical trial and error but what's interesting is, you know, so the version of MPT-7b, that model we open source, that version that is instruction fine-tuned, we took the MPT-7b, we took, you know, a data set, or I think we combined a couple of data sets that are just out there for, you know, instruction. I think it was the Dolly dataset from Databricks. So about 10 million tokens of
我想没有办法真正知道，对吧？你试图调高学习率，但并没有真正科学的方法说，好吧，你需要这么多的剧作家剧本才能拥有一个合理的模型。这就像其中一件事，很难计算，真的很难。是的，它仍然更多是经验主义的试错，但有趣的是（你知道的），MPT-7b 的那个版本，我们开源的那个模型，经过指令微调的那个版本，我们拿了 MPT-7b，我们拿了（你知道的）一个数据集，或者我想我们结合了几个现有的用于指令的数据集。我想那是 Databricks 的 Dolly 数据集。所以大约有 1000 万个 Token 的
data for instruction fine tuning. And basically within like a couple of hours on one node with eight GPUs, we fine tuned that model. So just to put things in perspective, the base model took us 10 days of hundreds of GPUs costing $200,000 to train. But to take that model and then instruction find unit for following instructions like we discussed earlier, that took us two hours with just eight GPUs costing us about 40 bucks. That's it.
指令微调数据。基本上在几个小时内，在一个带有 8 个 GPU 的节点上，我们就微调好了那个模型。所以为了让你对情况有个概念，基础模型花费了我们数百个 GPU 10 天的时间，耗资 20 万美元进行训练。但要拿到那个模型并对其进行指令微调，以便像我们之前讨论的那样遵循指令，只用了两个小时，只用了 8 个 GPU，花费了我们大约 40 美元。就是这样。
So this is definitely within reach for anyone out there. It's like the difference between buying a tractor or buying the seeds to plant, right? Yeah, it's a huge difference. And that actually kind of is a segue to, you know, we spoke about the first way to leverage LLMs, just call an API. The second way is take an open source model and either use it as is or fine tune it for your needs. Either way, you know, it's fairly accessible today, fairly cheap and available. And so what about serving? I want to use the time we have left to talk about that. Let's say you try Lama on Hugging Face. And, you know, a lot of these Hugging Face sites have a web UI where you can ask questions, you know, it's not as sophisticated as OpenAI's site, but it's good enough, you can type in your question, it'll generate an answer.
所以这绝对是外面的任何人都能触及的。这就像买拖拉机还是买要种植的种子之间的区别，对吧？是的，这是一个巨大的区别。这其实有点像是一个过渡，（你知道的），我们谈到了利用大语言模型的第一个方法，就是调用 API。第二个方法是拿一个开源模型，要么原封不动地使用它，要么针对你的需求对其进行微调。无论哪种方式（你知道的），它在今天都相当容易接近、相当便宜且随时可用。那么关于服务呢？我想利用我们剩下的时间来谈谈这个。假设你在 Hugging Face 上尝试了 Llama。而且（你知道的），很多这样的 Hugging Face 网站都有一个网页 UI，你可以在那里提问（你知道的），它不像 OpenAI 的网站那么复杂，但已经够好了，你可以输入你的问题，它会生成一个答案。
And you say, yep, this is good enough, you're you fine tune a model. And now you want to build a website or some service for people you had a because the model can't even fit on on your gpu like how do you even how do you serve the model do people use cpus to serve the model is that a thing what's the story there so if you take um you know for example mpt7b so or the lama7b so it's a 7 billion parameter model right every parameter let's, you know, two to four bytes, depending if you're using FP16 or FP32. Typically serving today is done with FP16 or more specifically BF16, you know, so cellular parameters times two bytes, that's, you know, 14 gigabytes. That actually does fit on kind of good GPUs today, like the NVIDIA A140 gigs,
然后你说，是的，这已经足够好了，你微调了一个模型。现在你想为人们建立一个网站或某种服务，因为模型甚至装不下你的 GPU，比如你究竟该如何提供模型服务？人们是用 CPU 来提供模型服务的吗？这也是一种做法吗？背后的故事是什么？所以如果你拿（你知道的），例如 MPT-7b，或者 Llama-7b，所以它是一个 70 亿参数的模型，对吧？每个参数（让我们，你知道的）两到四个字节，取决于你使用的是 FP16 还是 FP32。今天通常的服务都是用 FP16 完成的，或者更具体地说，是 BF16（你知道的），所以 70 亿个参数乘以两个字节，那是（你知道的）14 吉字节。这实际上确实适合当今的高端 GPU，比如 NVIDIA A10 40G，
or even the A10s, 24 gigs or 32 gigs of memory. So these production grade GPUs can, you know, one GPU can hold such a model. But then there's other complexity there. I mean, you know, first of all, when you're talking about text generation, you want it to be fast and efficient. Now, remember, the way these models work is they generate one word after the other, or one token, actually, after the other. So actually, the latency of inference matters a lot,
甚至 A10，24G 或 32G 的内存。所以这些生产级 GPU 可以（你知道的），一个 GPU 就可以容纳这样一个模型。但随后还有其他复杂性。我的意思是（你知道的），首先，当你谈论文本生成时，你会希望它快速且高效。现在，记住，这些模型的工作方式是它们一个接一个地生成单词，或者实际上是一个接一个地生成 Token。所以实际上，推理的延迟非常重要，
especially for interactive applications, because, you know, a typical response to a model is definitely not just one word. It typically has, I'd say, tens, some questions even hundreds of tokens. So we want the inference to be as optimal as possible. And that's definitely one, I think, area of development. Even if you play today with models like ChatGPT, it's streaming the output word by word, but you can still see that it takes a while.
特别是对于交互式应用程序，因为（你知道的），对模型的典型响应绝对不仅仅是一个单词。它通常有，我想说，几十个，有些问题甚至有数百个 Token。所以我们希望推理尽可能优化。这绝对是（你知道的）我认为开发的一个领域。即使你今天玩像 ChatGPT 这样的模型，它也是逐字流式传输输出的，但你仍然可以看到它需要一段时间。
So setting up optimized inference is one area where there's definitely more and more tooling. And I think there's more room for the machine learning community to invest in. Now, one thing about that, you know, with regular deep learning models, like predicting the probability of an event, you would want to serve on the CPU because you don't have a batch versus in training, you know, you have a batch of data. Is that true here or is even just generating one word better on a GPU? Yeah, so GPUs definitely can. I think where they become really cost efficient there is, like you said, handling a batch. Now, the tricky thing is when you want to
因此，建立优化的推理是一个领域，这里肯定有越来越多的工具。我认为机器学习社区还有更大的投资空间。现在，关于这一点（你知道的），对于常规的深度学习模型，比如预测事件的概率，你会想要在 CPU 上提供服务，因为你没有批处理，而在训练中（你知道的），你有一批数据。这里也是这样吗？还是说仅仅生成一个词在 GPU 上会更好？是的，所以 GPU 绝对可以。我认为它们在成本效益上真正发挥作用的地方是，就像你说的，处理批处理。现在，棘手的事情在于，当你想要
generate output for an input sequence, and let's say you want to generate 50 tokens, you have to first calculate a token number, you know, response token number zero, and then you feed it in to generate token response number one, right? And then, and so on and so forth. So there is a sequential angle to this. Where you can do batch even for inference is when you have, you know, you have a service and you have multiple requests, different requests at the same time,
为一个输入序列生成输出，比方说你想生成 50 个 Token，你必须首先计算一个 Token 编号（你知道的）响应 Token 编号 0，然后将其输入以生成 Token 响应编号 1，对吧？然后，以此类推。所以这里有一个序列化的角度。你可以甚至在推理中进行批处理的情况是，当你拥有（你知道的），你有一个服务，并且你同时有多个请求、不同的请求，
then you can batch. Oh, right. Yeah. But then you need scale to be able to handle something like that, or it's an offline process, like, you know, batch inference, which is typically offline, and then you can do those things.
那么你就可以进行批处理。哦，对了。是的。但随后你需要规模来能够处理类似的事情，或者它是一个离线过程，就像（你知道的）批处理推理，这通常是离线的，然后你就可以做那些事情。
Going back to the question of a CPU, so I think the main advantage of a CPU is just cost, right? Because GPUs are very expensive. I know Intel has been doing a lot of work to get their new CPU generation to be pretty good at handling transformer architecture so people can use it. You know, I have yet to see kind of inference of these kind of models work well on CPU. But I know it is an area actually Intel is working on. I even saw a demo. They did something which looked pretty promising. But then when you look at the details, it was their newest generation of CPUs.
回到关于 CPU 的问题，所以我认为 CPU 的主要优势只是成本，对吧？因为 GPU 非常昂贵。我知道英特尔一直在做大量工作，让他们的英特尔新一代 CPU 在处理 Transformer 架构方面变得相当不错，以便人们可以使用它。你知道，我还没怎么看到这类模型的推理在 CPU 上运行良好。但我知道这实际上是英特尔正在努力的一个领域。我甚至看过一个演示。他们做了一些看起来很有前途的事情。但当你查看细节时，那是他们最新一代的 CPU。
And actually the cost of that CPU, at least on the AWS, was actually the same as the cost of a low end GPU. So performance was good, but then cost, there was no difference. So yeah, I think, you know, if we look at the trend of, you know, computing and processors is that the cost of running complex workloads, you know, always goes down, right? And I expect this to happen. So there's been a lot of interesting work by the community of folks kind of allowing you to run, you know, these models on commodity hardware. There's something called Lama CPP, I think, that someone hacked together where it's, you know, super efficient, you know, low-level implementation of inference for LAMA on a commodity CPU.
而且实际上该 CPU 的成本，至少在 AWS 上，实际上与低端 GPU 的成本相同。所以性能很好，但成本上没有区别。所以是的，我认为（你知道的），如果我们看看计算和处理器的发展趋势，那就是运行复杂工作负载的成本（你知道的）总是在下降，对吧？我预计这种情况会发生。所以社区中有很多人做了很多有趣的工作（你知道的），允许你在商用硬件上运行（你知道的）这些模型。有一个叫做 Llama CPP 的东西，我想，是某人拼凑出来的，它是（你知道的）超级高效的（你知道的）低级实现，用于在商用 CPU 上运行 LAMA 的推理。
So I think it will definitely get there, although we're not there now. It actually brings me to, there's another important angle of inference. And again, that's like a differentiating factor, I think, between using an API, a model behind an API versus using either your own model or an open source model. And that issue is a huge issue, actually, of data privacy. You know, when you are leveraging a model behind an API, you have to send your data outside of a premise into another service.
所以我认为它绝对会实现这一点，尽管我们现在还没有到达那里。这其实让我想到了，推理还有另一个重要的角度。而且，这就像是一个区分因素，我认为，在使用 API、API 背后的模型与使用你自己的模型或开源模型之间。这个问题是一个巨大的问题，实际上是关于数据隐私的巨大问题。（你知道的），当你利用 API 背后的模型时，你必须将你的数据发送到企业内部之外的另一个服务中。
Yeah, this was in the news. I think I hesitate to get the company wrong here but i'm pretty sure it was samsung the employees were using open ai and then yeah somehow i don't know what actually happened there but somehow uh opening i got their data or their schematics or something yeah so yeah there was that that was a big story in the news where um i think engineers at Samsung, that was the report, they were using chat GPT to kind of write down some of their plans. And then that data somehow leaked.
是的，这上了新闻。我想我在这里说错公司名字可能会有些犹豫，但我很确信那是三星，员工们在使用 OpenAI，然后（你知道的）不知怎么的，我不知道那里到底发生了什么，但不知怎么的（你知道的）OpenAI 得到了他们的代码或原理图之类的东西。是的，所以，这是一个很大的新闻故事，其中（你知道的）三星的工程师，那是报道，他们正在使用 ChatGPT 来写下他们的一些计划。然后这些数据不知怎么地泄露了。
It's not clear if it was leaked because OpenAI is using data people send their service for inference, they're using it to retrain the model. And then the model memorizes some of what it's seeing. And then it leaked in a response somewhere else. Yeah, I think somebody else searched for like the model number. You know, a competitor was like, tell me more about the Samsung S4000.
目前尚不清楚它是否泄露是因为 OpenAI 正在使用人们发送到他们服务进行推理的数据，他们用它来重新训练模型。然后模型记住了它所看到的一部分内容。然后它在其他地方的某个响应中泄露了。是的，我想其他人搜索了像型号编号这样的东西。你知道，一个竞争对手说，告诉我更多关于三星 S4000 的信息。
And OpenAI was like, sure, here's what I know. Yeah, so I don't know if OpenAI, I don't know if they changed it yet, but if you're using the free version of ChatGPT, the default is opt-in, meaning many people are not aware of it, but you're by default opt-in to share your data with OpenAI and then use it for training their model and whatnot. And that's really something to pay attention to.
而 OpenAI 说，当然，这是我知道的。是的，所以我不知道 OpenAI，我不知道他们是否已经更改了它，但如果你使用的是 ChatGPT 的免费版本，默认是选择加入（opt-in），这意味着许多人并不知道这一点，但你默认是选择加入，将你的数据与 OpenAI 共享，然后将其用于训练他们的模型等等。这真的是需要注意的事情。
And I think the industry needs to mature a little bit. And I also, my personal take is that I think there should be legislation that governs how these models are used and the privacy of data and all that stuff. But that's just something
而且我认为这个行业需要稍微成熟一点。而且我也，我个人的看法是，我认为应该有立法来规范这些模型的的使用方式以及数据的隐私等等。但这只是一些
for everyone to remember. There are a lot of advantages of using a model behind an API. And we went through that, those advantages. But one drawback is definitely if they if you care about data privacy, if you're like in finance, or healthcare, or similar industries, you probably don't want to send your data over the wire somewhere. Or,
供每个人记住的事情。使用 API 背后的模型有很多优势。我们已经讨论过了，那些优势。但一个缺点绝对是，如果你关心数据隐私，如果你身处金融、医疗或类似行业，你可能不想把你的数据通过网络发送到某个地方。或者，
you know, you want to get very strong, right, guarantees from your service provider about how this data is going to be used or is not going to be used yeah i mean i think the the old adage you get what you pay for applies here you know if you're using a free api and open ai is spending you know we talked about hundreds of thousands of dollars you know on on keeping these gpu machines up even to do inference um you know you're giving something back right and so you know, you know, using HuggingFace or Mosaic or one of these services where you're paying for the service, you know, you could probably get much better privacy guarantees. Yeah. The other thing, by the way, is also cost. So what people are finding out is when they use models behind APIs, then I think at small scale and prototyping,
（你知道的），你希望从你的服务提供商那里获得非常强烈的（你知道的）保证，关于这些数据将如何被使用或不会被使用。是的，我的意思是，我认为“一分钱一分货”这句老话在这里适用（你知道的），如果你使用的是免费 API，而 OpenAI 正在花（你知道的，我们谈到了数十万美元）（你知道的）来维持这些 GPU 机器运转甚至只是进行推理，（你知道的）你是在回报一些东西，对吧？所以（你知道的），使用 Hugging Face 或 Mosaic 或其中一个你为服务付费的服务，（你知道的）你可能会获得好得多的隐私保证。另一件事，顺便说一下，也是成本。所以人们发现的是，当他们使用 API 背后的模型时，我认为在小规模和原型设计阶段，
it's very cheap, cost-effective. But if and when this becomes a core use case for your application, it's becoming very expensive, especially if you have a large-scale operation. So that's also something, you know, I think people are realizing sometimes a bit too late, and that's also something to you know, I think people are realizing sometimes a bit too late. And that's also something to factor in because you can get much better cost efficiency if
它非常便宜，具有成本效益。但如果这成为了你应用程序的核心用例，它就会变得非常昂贵，尤其是如果你拥有大规模运营的话。所以这也是一件事（你知道的），我认为人们有时意识到得有点晚，这也是一件事（你知道的），我认为人们有时意识到得有点晚。这也是一个需要考虑的因素，因为如果你
you are serving your own model or either an open source model or a model you trained. If you serve it on your own infrastructure, of course, you need to set this up. And there are some services that help you do that, including Mosaic ML, but it's much more cost efficient than actually using an external service that has a margin and whatnot. So cost is becoming a thing at scale. Yeah, I think if everyone uses OpenAI, then it's driving towards a monopoly, which just putting my economist hat on results in infinite profitability for OpenAI. You know, conversely, if everyone's using their own model, and it's just a matter of who can host your model, that's driving to zero profitability, or like infinite competition, which is good for you as a person who wants to use the model. So it sounds like, you know, it doesn't take a lot of
在自己的基础设施上为自己的模型（无论是开源模型还是你训练的模型）提供服务，你可以获得好得多的成本效益。当然，你需要设置这个。有一些服务可以帮助你做到这一点，包括 Mosaic ML，但它比实际使用具有利润率等因素的外部服务要具有高得多的成本效益。所以成本在规模化时成了一个问题。是的，我想如果每个人都使用 OpenAI，那么它就会走向垄断，站在我的经济学家立场来看，这会导致 OpenAI 获得无限的盈利能力。相反，如果每个人都使用他们自己的模型，这只是一个谁能托管你的模型的问题，这会把盈利能力推向零，或者像无限的竞争，这对于作为一个想使用模型的人的你来说是件好事。所以听起来（你知道的），这不需要花很多
money or time. It really takes you kind of out there building those skills to, you know, grab the right data set, grab the right model, try a bunch of different fine tuning and learn how that system works. And in the end, end up with a model that can create some unique value for you or for a addressable market that you have. So one thing about, I want to dive into Mosaic, the company here. So there's a ton of folks out there, listeners who are really interested in this technology, just like there are people across the world in all disciplines interested, and they would love to get their foot in the door, work more with AI and machine learning and generative AI.
钱或时间。它真正需要的是你走出去建立这些技能（你知道的），抓取正确的数据集，抓取正确的模型，尝试一堆不同的微调，并了解该系统是如何运作的。最终，以一个能够为你自己或为你拥有的可寻址市场创造一些独特价值的模型结束。所以关于一件事，我想深入探讨 Mosaic 这家公司。所以有大量的人，听众们对这项技术非常感兴趣，就像世界各地各个学科的人们都很感兴趣一样，他们很乐意能够跨入这个门槛，更多地与人工智能、机器学习和生成式人工智能一起工作。
And so talk a little bit about what's it like at Mosaic and what kind of folks you're trying to hire for and just general kind of job seeking advice. Yeah. So let's start with Mosaic. So we're still pretty early stage startup. We're now about 60 employees. Most of us are in SF, but we also have a couple of other offices, including in New York and even Copenhagen. And we're really, you know, kind of relatively small team, just trying to do a good thing by making state-of-the-art AI with the focus of generative AI just more accessible.
所以请谈谈在 Mosaic 工作是什么感觉，你们正试图招聘什么样的人，以及关于求职的一般性建议。好的，让我们从 Mosaic 开始。所以我们仍然是一个非常早期的初创公司。我们现在大约有 60 名员工。我们大多数人在旧金山，但我们也有其他几个办公室，包括在纽约甚至哥本哈根。我们真的是（你知道的）一个相对较小的团队，只想通过使最先进的人工智能（重点是生成式人工智能）更容易获得来做好事。
So any organization out there, that's what we're out to do. Any organization out there should be able to, you know, leverage these models in whatever way works for them, you know, a model behind an API, which we offer, or open-source models that we open source, make available to the community, or pre-training and fine-tuning your own model. And we think there is, you know,
所以外面的任何组织，这就是我们要做的。外面的任何组织都应该能够（你知道的）以对他们行之有效的方式利用这些模型（你知道的），我们提供的 API 背后的模型，或者我们开源并向社区提供的开源模型，或者预训练和微调你自己的模型。我们认为这里有（你知道的）
great business opportunity with that. And it also, it's going to kind of really help kind of the next generation of startups, as well as big enterprises to use AI. Yeah, so, and then we're hiring actually. So, you know, the business has been going well, you know, we're seeing good traction with customers. We're seeing good traction with the community and we are growing the team and we're hiring across, you know,
巨大的商业机会。而且它也将真正（你知道的）帮助下一代初创公司以及大型企业使用人工智能。是的，所以，我们正在招聘。所以（你知道的）业务进展顺利，（你知道的）我们看到了客户的良好吸引力。我们看到了社区的良好吸引力，我们正在壮大团队，并且我们正在跨部门招聘，
software engineers, both for our cloud platform, as well as for machine learning runtimes. We hire researchers for our fantastic research team that is using our platform to, you know, build these amazing models like MPT that we've open sourced. So there's researchers, we are hiring interns across these both teams, both the research team and the engineering team. And then we hire for other functions. You know, we hire across product, technical program management, recruiting. So it's really kind of, you know, I feel that the team is kind of hitting on all cylinders. And then as part of that,
软件工程师，既包括我们的云平台，也包括我们的机器学习运行时。我们为我们出色的研究团队招聘研究人员，他们正在使用我们的平台来（你知道的）构建这些令人惊叹的模型，比如我们开源的 MPT。所以有研究人员，我们在这两个团队中招聘实习生，研究团队和工程团队。然后我们为其他职能部门招聘。你知道，我们跨产品、技术项目管理、招聘进行招聘。所以这真的是（你知道的），我觉得团队正在全速前进。作为其中的一部分，
we're also continuing our growth. Yeah, it's really exciting. And, you know, I guess I'm biased, but I'm really excited about both the mission of what we're trying to do as well as kind of the the culture and team at mosaic cool it makes sense and so you know as we talked about for you know a relatively small sum you can take the mpt model and you can fine-tune it to do playwright If someone does playwrights of Shakespeare, let me know. I would love to just add me on Twitter.
我们也在继续增长。是的，这真的很令人兴奋。而且（你知道的）我想我有偏见，但我对我们正在努力做的事情的使命以及 Mosaic 的文化和团队感到非常兴奋。太棒了，这说得通。所以（你知道的）正如我们所讨论的，对于（你知道的）相对较小的金额，你可以拿到 MPT 模型，并且你可以对其进行微调来编写剧本。如果有人做莎士比亚剧本，请告诉我。我很乐意，只要在 Twitter 上加我。
I would love to see that. But I think the best way to get noticed at a company like Mosaic is to use the product, right? And to build something and have a portfolio of accomplishments that you could do relatively low cost kind of adjacent to that so if someone's a student you know a college student even high school student you know is mosaic a tool for them is it something that they should know about for when they go into industry is there is there sort of a free tier like what is the story. Yeah, great question. So at Mosaic, we do have a few open source components
我很乐意看到这一点。但我认为在像 Mosaic 这样的公司获得关注的最佳方式是使用产品，对吧？并构建一些东西，并拥有一份你可以以相对较低的成本在其附近完成的成就组合。所以如果有人是一名学生，（你知道的）大学生甚至是高中生，（你知道的）Mosaic 是他们的工具吗？这是否是他们在进入行业时应该了解的事情？有没有（你知道的）某种免费层？背后的故事是什么？是的，好问题。所以在 Mosaic，我们确实有一些开源组件
that anyone can use. So there is the models I mentioned earlier, the MPT series of models. But there's also a training library called Composer. It's a PyTorch training library, which just helps train PyTorch models faster and better. And there's also a streaming dataset library, which is really useful for training models when you need to stream all the training data from cloud buckets.
任何人都可以使用。所以有我刚才提到的模型，MPT 系列模型。但还有一个名为 Composer 的训练库。它是一个 PyTorch 训练库，只是有助于更快、更好地训练 PyTorch 模型。还有一个流式数据集库，当你需要从云存储桶中流式传输所有训练数据时，这对于训练模型非常有用。
However, the product itself, so far it's been really geared towards enterprises, meaning there's no free tier or community tier where people can just easily get started with the platform. And the reason it was designed this way is just kind of how the company evolved, right? You know, at the end of the day, it is a business. And we were going after enterprises initially to establish the business. And that has gone really well.
然而，产品本身，到目前为止，它确实主要面向企业，这意味着没有免费层或社区层，人们可以只用平台轻松上手。这样设计的原因只是公司的演变方式，对吧？（你知道的）归根结底，它是一项业务。我们最初是为了建立业务而面向企业的。这进展得非常顺利。
And the next thing on our plate is offering some sort of a community tier where, you know, a broader set of practitioners out there can get started using what we have to offer. And this will come soon. And I think at that point, definitely, it's going to be very easy for anyone to just get started, try us out, either use our models as APIs or fine tune either our models or any model out there that is available on the Hugging Face Hub or GitHub or anywhere else. As well as, of course, kind of pre-training your own model. Although this tends to usually cater more to the enterprises that have enough data and have the budgets to pre-train these models. So stay tuned. It will come.
我们盘子里的下一件事是提供某种社区层，（你知道的）更广泛的从业者可以开始使用我们所提供的服务。这很快就会到来。我认为到那时，绝对地，任何人都可以非常容易地上手，试用我们，无论是将我们的模型用作 API，还是微调我们的模型或 Hugging Face Hub、GitHub 或其他任何地方可用的任何模型。以及当然（你知道的）预训练你自己的模型。尽管这往往更多地迎合那些拥有足够数据和预算来预训练这些模型的大企业。所以请拭目以待。它会到来的。
And at that point, it's going to be amazing. I'm really looking forward to that moment where we kind of open the floodgates and allow the community to really engage fully with us. Cool. That makes sense. I mean, in the meantime, folks can get the MPT model. They can get all of the the weights the pie torch code so that they can continue training on their own data set and
到那时，它将是惊人的。我真的很期待那个时刻，我们有点打开了闸门，允许社区真正与我们充分互动。酷。这说得通。我的意思是，在此期间，人们可以获得 MPT 模型。他们可以获得所有的权重、PyTorch 代码，以便他们可以在自己的数据集上继续训练，并且
there's there's a whole myriad of different services out there so if this sounds cool to you you should you should uh you know put in the sort of sweat equity here to uh to build something neat uh definitely email us uh you know tag us on social media with anything you build. We've actually, inside Baseball here, we've been really good at placing people. I've gotten emails lately from people who have been on the show representing a variety of different companies saying, oh, we have our first intern who found out about us from the show.
这里有各种各样的不同服务，所以如果这听起来很酷，你应该（你知道的）在这里投入汗水资本来构建一些整洁的东西。绝对给我们发电子邮件，（你知道的）在社交媒体上用你构建的任何东西给我们贴上标签。我们实际上，内部消息，我们在安置人才方面一直很擅长。我最近收到了一些电子邮件，来自曾在节目中代表各种不同公司的嘉宾，他们说，哦，我们有了第一个通过节目了解我们的实习生。
So I think that's a real testament to the audience out there. You folks are super motivated, highly technical, which is really great to see that we're able to sort of, Patrick and I can kind of connect to interested parties here, which is awesome. So we'll put the links to Mosaic ML and their careers page, all of that on the site,
所以我认为这是对广大听众的一个真正证明。你们超级积极，技术娴熟，很高兴看到我们能够（你知道的），帕特里克和我能够在这里与感兴趣的人建立联系，这太棒了。所以我们将把 Mosaic ML 的链接和他们的职业页面，所有这些都放在网站上，
if that's something that interests you folks out there. Hag thank you so much for coming on the show you know i think we did an awesome job kind of covering you know in the audio format um you know how how this whole system is evolving how it works technically uh there'll be tons of resources of the show notes for people to follow up and i want to just really appreciate you uh you know spending time with us today thank you jason thanks for having me and uh i really enjoyed this this chat cool thanks everyone out there have a good one music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the
如果那是你们这些听众感兴趣的事情。Hag，非常感谢你来到节目中，（你知道的）我认为我们在音频格式中做得非常棒，（你知道的）涵盖了（你知道的）整个系统是如何演变的，它是如何从技术上运作的，节目笔记中会有大量的资源供大家跟进，我只想由衷地感谢你（你知道的）今天花时间与我们在一起。谢谢你，杰森，谢谢你邀请我，（你知道的）我真的很享受这次聊天。酷，谢谢大家，祝大家过得愉快。Eric Barn 所作的音乐。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下分发。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以重新混合、改编
work but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
该作品，但您必须向我和帕特里克提供署名，并以相同方式共享。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。